Local news is in decline across Canada, and this is bad news for all of us. With less local news, noise, rumors, and misinformation fill the void, and it gets harder to separate truth from fiction. That's why CBC News is putting more journalists in more places across Canada, reporting on the ground from where you live, telling the stories that matter to all of us, because local news is big news. Choose news, not noise.
加拿大各地的本地新闻正在衰落，这对我们所有人来说都是坏消息。随着本地新闻的减少，噪音、谣言和虚假信息填补了空白，人们也越来越难以分辨真假。这就是为什么加拿大广播公司（CBC）新闻部正在加拿大各地部署更多的记者，深入你们的生活社区进行实地报道，讲述与我们每个人息息相关的故事，因为本地新闻就是重大新闻。选择新闻，拒绝噪音。
CBC News. This episode is brought to you by Tellus Online Security. Oh, tax season is the worst. You mean hack season? Sorry, what? Yeah, cybercriminals love tax forms. But I've got Tellus Online Security. It helps protect against identity theft and financial fraud
CBC新闻。本期节目由Tellus在线安全公司赞助播出。哦，报税季真是太糟糕了。你是说黑客季吗？抱歉，你说什么？是的，网络犯罪分子最喜欢税表了。但我有Tellus在线安全服务。它有助于防范身份盗窃和金融欺诈，
so I can stress less during tax season or any season. Plan started just $12 a month. Learn more at tellus.com slash online security. No one can prevent all cybercrime or identity theft. Conditions apply. Amazon presents Laura versus Fruitflies. Swarming your fruit and terrorizing your kitchen, these little freaks multiply at a rate that would make a rabbit say yo.
所以我可以在报税季或任何时候少操点心。套餐每月仅需12美元起。欲了解更多信息，请访问tellus.com斜杠online security。没有人能预防所有的网络犯罪或身份盗窃。适用相关条款。亚马逊为您呈现《劳拉大战果蝇》。这些小怪物成群结队地涌入，骚扰你的厨房，它们的繁殖速度快到会让兔子都说“哟，
Chill. But Laura shopped on Amazon and saved on cleaning spray, countertop wipes, and fly traps. Hey, fruit flies, your baby boom ends here. Save the Everyday with Amazon. Please allow me to introduce myself. I am the owner of faulty towers. And may I welcome your war? You war, you all, you all.
冷静点”。但劳拉在亚马逊上购物，省下了清洁喷雾、台面湿巾和捕蝇器的钱。嘿，果蝇，你们的婴儿潮到此为止了。用亚马逊节省日常开支。请允许我自我介绍一下。我是“福尔蒂旅馆”的老板。欢迎各位光临，你们的战争，你们的战争，你们，你们，你们。
And hope that your stay will be a happy one. Now, would you like to eat first? Or would you like a drink before, savour? Closed by us will be tied up with piano wire. Sorry, sorry. May I say, How pleased we are to have some Europeans here now that we are on the continent. Didn't vote for it myself, quite honestly.
希望你们能住得愉快。现在，你们想先吃饭吗？还是在享用之前想喝杯饮料？我们这里的一切都将用钢琴线捆绑起来。抱歉，抱歉。请允许我说，既然我们现在身处欧洲大陆，能有几位欧洲客人真是太高兴了。老实说，我本人并没有投票支持加入。
But now that we're in, I'm determined to make it work. So I'd like to welcome you all to Britain. We're all friends now, eh? All in the market together. All differences for cotton. And no need at all to mention the war. So that was Torquie Hotelia Basil Fulte. as played by John Cleese in Fulte Towers
但既然我们已经加入了，我决心让它发挥作用。所以我想欢迎大家来到英国。我们现在都是朋友了，对吧？都在同一个市场里。所有的分歧都……棉花。根本没必要提那场战争。以上就是约翰·克里斯在《福尔蒂旅馆》中饰演的巴兹尔·福尔蒂。
and the episode that we were citing there was the Germans which was first broadcast on the 24th of October 1975 and I'm actually so exhausted from doing that that I just need to catch my breath Tom have a rest I'm going to have a breath but just to say
我们刚才引用的那一集是《德国人》，首播于1975年10月24日。说实话，演完这段我太累了，我得喘口气。汤姆，休息一下吧。我要喘口气，但只是想说，
I mean Fulte Towers consistently voted the greatest British sitcom of all time but it's also a brilliant window under the state of the nation in the mid-1970s coming out just as Harold Wilson is starting his second stint as Prime Minister between 1974 and 976. And in that episode and in all the other episodes, it captures the mood of the times, doesn't it, Dominic? So the hotel is kind of very shabby. The management style of Basil is less than suboptimal.
我的意思是，《福尔蒂旅馆》一直被评为英国史上最伟大的情景喜剧，但它也是观察1970年代中期英国国情的一扇绝佳窗口，当时哈罗德·威尔逊刚刚开始他作为首相的第二个任期（1974年至1976年）。多米尼克，那一集以及其他所有剧集都捕捉到了当时的时代氛围，不是吗？旅馆看起来非常破旧。巴兹尔的管理风格简直是“次优”的。
He's obsessed with class. He's always kind of fawning around his betters and kind of kicking, well, actually kind of clipping around the earhole, those who are employed by him, most notably his ludicrous Leonette Spanish waiter Manuel. He's got this loveless marriage with the very tyrannical Sybil. And there is a retired major who is always making racist jokes, complaining about strikes and loves a test match. And I guess that probably that passage where he meets a load of Germans, he's knocked
他痴迷于阶级。他总是对地位比他高的人卑躬屈膝，而对他的雇员——尤其是他那滑稽的西班牙侍者曼努埃尔——却动辄拳打脚踢。他与专横的西比尔维持着一段毫无温情的婚姻。还有一个退休少校，总是讲种族主义笑话，抱怨罢工，还热爱板球比赛。我想，在他遇到那群德国人的那一幕，他大概是
himself on the head, hasn't he? So he's gone a kind of little bit mad. With a moose. Yes, that's right. And so all the kind of buried thoughts of the average strangulated middle-class Englishman, it just kind of pours out of him, unmediated, and it all revolves around the war. Yeah. So at one point they say to him, will you stop talking about the war? And he says, you started it?
撞到头了吧？所以他有点疯了。带着一只驼鹿。是的，没错。于是，普通焦虑的中产阶级英国人内心深处被压抑的想法，就这样毫无修饰地倾泻而出，而且全都围绕着那场战争。是的。所以有一次他们对他说：“你能别再提那场战争了吗？”他说：“是你们先挑起的！”
We did not start it? Yes, you did. You invaded Poland. And so on and so forth. And Basil is absolutely, I mean, one of the glorious things about Basil is a comic creation. He is a textbook, kind of frustrated middle class conservative, isn't he? There's no doubt whatsoever that he's always placed his vote in the Tory column. And so when a fire extinguisher goes off in his face in this episode, the Germans, he knows whom to blame. He says, it sits there for months and when you actually have a fire, it blows your head off. I mean, what is happening to this country? It's Bloody Wilson! And this is the story of today's episode. It's about Basil and the Germans, or rather, it's about the first Brexit referendum in June 1975, when Britain took the fateful decision not to leave what became the EU. And it's about Basil's bet noir, bloody Wilson,
“我们没有挑起战争！”“是的，你们挑起了！你们入侵了波兰。”诸如此类。巴兹尔绝对是……我的意思是，巴兹尔作为一个喜剧创作最辉煌的地方在于，他是一个教科书式的、充满挫败感的中产阶级保守派，不是吗？毫无疑问，他总是把票投给保守党。所以当这一集《德国人》里灭火器在他脸上喷发时，他知道该怪谁。他说：“它在那儿放了几个月，当你真的着火时，它却把你的头炸飞了。我的意思是，这个国家到底怎么了？都是该死的威尔逊干的！”这就是今天这一集的故事。它是关于巴兹尔和德国人的，或者更确切地说，是关于1975年6月英国第一次脱欧公投的，当时英国做出了一个决定，不离开后来成为欧盟的组织。这也是关于巴兹尔的眼中钉——该死的威尔逊，
and how Harold Wilson struggled to stop Britain plunging into hyperinflation and complete economic meltdown in the course of 19. So last time, we talked about some of the background to all this. So to remind people, a very demoralised and sort of hangdog Britain is reeling after the 1973 oil shock. The Tory Prime Minister, Ted Heath, has tried to impose his wage controls. The coal miners rebelled. They blew his economic policy apart. He called an election in February 74. The result was stalemate. Back came Basil's nemesis, Harold Wilson, the leader of the Labour Party as Prime Minister for the second time. He paid off the miners, paid off the other unions. He called another election in October and he won a three-seat majority. And Dominic, just to remind people that that three-seat majority means that Wilson's position is very, very weak because he has to pay attention to every MP behind him because they now
以及哈罗德·威尔逊如何在1975年期间努力阻止英国陷入恶性通货膨胀和彻底的经济崩溃。所以上次我们谈到了这一切的一些背景。提醒一下大家，在1973年石油危机之后，士气低落、垂头丧气的英国正处于动荡之中。保守党首相泰德·希思试图实施工资管制。煤矿工人反抗了。他们彻底摧毁了他的经济政策。他在1974年2月宣布大选。结果陷入僵局。巴兹尔的宿敌——工党领袖哈罗德·威尔逊——第二次出任首相。他安抚了矿工，安抚了其他工会。他在10月再次宣布大选，并赢得了三个席位的多数优势。多米尼克，提醒一下大家，那三个席位的多数意味着威尔逊的地位非常、非常脆弱，因为他必须关注身后的每一位议员，因为他们现在
exercise incredible power. Exactly right. So we did a series in 2024 about the year 174, and we talked a lot about Wilson and that, but I know we've got a lot of new listeners since then. So we should remind ourselves a bit about Wilson. Once such a pivotal figure in British politics, kind of forgotten today, but he won four elections out of five in the 1960s and 1970s,
拥有难以置信的权力。完全正确。所以我们在2024年做了一个关于1974年的系列节目，我们谈了很多关于威尔逊的内容，但我知道从那以后我们有了很多新听众。所以我们应该回顾一下威尔逊。他曾经是英国政坛如此关键的人物，今天却被遗忘了，但他曾在1960年代和1970年代赢得了五次大选中的四次，
a record that seems very unlikely to be equaled anytime soon. So Wilson was born in West Yorkshire in 1916. He went to Oxford and he was an absolutely brilliant student, supposedly got the best mark in economics that anyone had ever got. He became an economics dawn, and then a government statistician, became a Labour MP, then Labor Leader, then a modernising Prime Minister between 1964 and 1970. Wilson, I think we said this before, he's a very likable character, I think. He's a very kind man, he's generous. As a politician, he is resilient,
这个记录在短期内似乎不太可能被打破。威尔逊1916年出生于西约克郡。他去了牛津大学，是一个绝对的天才学生，据说拿到了有史以来最好的经济学成绩。他成为了一名经济学讲师，然后是政府统计学家，后来成为工党议员、工党领袖，并在1964年至1970年间担任现代化改革派首相。威尔逊，我想我们之前说过，他是一个非常讨人喜欢的角色。他是一个很善良的人，很慷慨。作为一名政治家，他很有韧性，
he's pragmatic, he's very cunning, his whiliness is legendary. He has moved over the course of his career, you know, it's a very common trajectory. He's started out kind of on the left, and he's moved steadily more and more towards the centre. As a man, his tastes are modest and unpretentious. He loves Agatha Christie. He loves golf. He loves Gilbert and Sullivan. And he loves scouting, doesn't he? Above all, he loves scouting. Boy scouts, I mean, he can recite the scouting oath, and he takes it very seriously. Does he have a pair of very tight scouting shorts? He loves his tight shorts and he wears them on holiday in the Silly Isles
他务实，非常狡猾，他的机智是传奇性的。在他的职业生涯中，他经历了一个非常普遍的轨迹：他起初偏左，然后稳步向中间靠拢。作为一个男人，他的品味朴实且不矫揉造作。他喜欢阿加莎·克里斯蒂。他喜欢高尔夫。他喜欢吉尔伯特和萨利文。他喜欢童子军，不是吗？最重要的是，他热爱童子军。我是说男童子军，他能背诵童子军誓词，而且非常认真地对待它。他有一条非常紧的童子军短裤吗？他喜欢他的紧身短裤，并且在锡利群岛度假时会穿上它们。
so he will go to these islands they are south of Cornwall and he will go to these islands that's sort of are trapped in sort of the 1950s time warp and I've seen a photo of his house at the Sili Isles, never seen it in the flesh it's really modest kind of unpretentious
所以他会去这些岛屿，它们在康沃尔郡的南边，他会去这些仿佛被困在1950年代时间扭曲里的岛屿。我见过一张他在锡利群岛房子的照片，虽然没亲眼见过，但真的很朴实，不矫揉造作。
I think it's a bungalow so one story you know very simple place for a British Prime Minister to be going on holiday now that first government that he had in the 1960s was a bit of a mess. The economy grew, but basically he's kicked from crisis to crisis. There's a sense that all his grand plans didn't really work out,
我想那是一栋平房，所以只有一层，你知道，对于一位英国首相来说，这是一个非常简单的度假场所。他在1960年代的第一个政府有点混乱。经济增长了，但基本上他从一个危机走向另一个危机。人们有一种感觉，他所有的宏伟计划并没有真正实现，
that he was completely beleaguered and overwhelmed by events, and the voters booted him out in 1970. But that was because England lost at football, wasn't it? Well, England lost to West Germany, unexpectedly in the 1970 World Cup, just a few days before the vote, and Wilson always said that was the reason. I don't actually think that was the reason. Okay.
他完全被事件所困扰和淹没，选民在1970年把他赶下了台。但那是因为英格兰在足球比赛中输了，不是吗？嗯，英格兰在1970年世界杯上出人意料地输给了西德，就在投票前几天，威尔逊一直说那是原因。我其实不认为那是原因。好吧。
Might have made a few voters change to their mind. space. So he comes back in 74, you know, not through any great achievement of his own, but really because Heath has shot himself in the foot. He's 57 at this point, but he seems much older. He has a very weary, careworn, kind of listless air. So during the 74 campaign, the Sunday Times described him as looking withdrawn, nervous, tentative, apprehensive, not to say distinctly bored. And I think that's absolutely right. He is all of those things. He's often ill. He has endless colds and stomach upsets. He's got endless problems with his eyes getting infected. And his chief aides, so they are his very acerbic press chief, Joe Haynes, and his chief policy
可能让一些选民改变了主意。所以他在74年回归，你知道，不是因为他自己有什么伟大的成就，而是因为希思搬起石头砸了自己的脚。他当时57岁，但看起来老得多。他有一种非常疲惫、忧心忡忡、无精打采的气质。所以在74年的竞选期间，《星期日泰晤士报》形容他看起来“退缩、紧张、迟疑、忧虑，甚至明显感到厌倦”。我认为这完全正确。他确实就是那样。他经常生病。他有没完没了的感冒和胃部不适。他的眼睛经常感染。他的首席助手——他那尖刻的新闻主管乔·海恩斯，以及他的首席政策
advisor, who's a young academic from the LSE called Bernard Donahue, who writes a brilliant diary during this period. These aids thought that these ailments of Wilson's were often stress-related, though they might also have been foreshadowings of the dementia from which he suffers at the beginning of the 1980s. So the onset of that dementia is only a few years away. Wilson is drinking a lot. So Bernard Donahue's diaries for 1975 often describe him drinking four or five glasses of brandy or whiskey at lunch,
顾问，一位来自伦敦政治经济学院（LSE）的年轻学者伯纳德·多纳休（他在这段时期写了一本精彩的日记）——认为威尔逊的这些疾病通常与压力有关，尽管它们也可能是他在1980年代初所患痴呆症的前兆。所以那种痴呆症的发作离现在只有几年了。威尔逊喝了很多酒。伯纳德·多纳休1975年的日记经常描述他在午餐时喝四五杯白兰地或威士忌，
especially when he's got to go to the commons and argue with Margaret Thatcher. I mean, I suppose it worked for Pitt, didn't it? Yeah, but Pitt was drinking wine, wasn't he? Or port, a bottle of port. I think there's a big difference in drinking a glass of port and drinking a massive glass of brandy, I would say. I think it's a noble British tradition. It is a British tradition.
尤其是在他要去下议院与玛格丽特·撒切尔辩论的时候。我的意思是，我想这对皮特（小威廉·皮特）来说是有效的，不是吗？是的，但皮特喝的是葡萄酒，不是吗？或者波特酒，一瓶波特酒。我认为喝一杯波特酒和喝一大杯白兰地有很大区别。我认为这是一种高尚的英国传统。这确实是一种英国传统。
But sometimes he comes very close to disaster. So an example in November 1975, Donahue recalls that Wilson went to a diplomatic lunch. And then at this lunch, Joe Haynes said he was all over the place and drank too much. And then he went to the Commons, gave it absolutely shambolic performance. this is before there's any broadcasting TV or radio in the Commons. So the public don't get to hear this, but he is slurring his words, and the Tory is kind of jeering at him with absolute delight that he's making such a spectacle of himself. Right, because Tories are never drunk at the dispatch box.
但有时他非常接近灾难。例如在1975年11月，多纳休回忆说威尔逊去参加了一个外交午宴。在这次午宴上，乔·海恩斯说他完全不在状态，喝得太多了。然后他去了下议院，表现得一塌糊涂。这还是在下议院没有电视或广播转播之前。所以公众听不到这些，但他说话含糊不清，保守党人嘲笑他，对他出丑感到非常高兴。对，因为保守党人在下议院从不喝醉。
They're all marinated on port, so that by this point. Now, part of the reason he's drinking is obviously he's under such pressure, and the pressure is both political and personal. So in the 1974 series, we described this sort of Harold Pinter style struggle between Wilson, his long-suffering wife, Mary, who hates politics, is gutted that he's prime minister. Very good poet, isn't she? She wants to hang out with John Betchman, her friend John Betcha and write poems.
到那时他们都沉浸在波特酒里了。现在，他喝酒的部分原因显然是他承受着巨大的压力，这种压力既是政治上的，也是个人生活中的。在1974年的系列节目中，我们描述了威尔逊和他那长期受苦的妻子玛丽之间那种哈罗德·品特式的挣扎，玛丽讨厌政治，对他是首相感到非常沮丧。她是一位很好的诗人，不是吗？她想和约翰·贝杰曼（她的朋友）待在一起写诗。
And his political secretary, Marcia Williams, who is the daughter of a Northamptonshire builder. Very much friend of the show. Very much a friend of the rest is history. She, when we did, and this would be incomprehensible to many listeners, but we did an episode about historical love island in which. she copped off with Judas Ascariot. And proved too much for him, I think. Yeah, I think so.
还有他的政治秘书玛西娅·威廉姆斯，她是北安普敦郡一位建筑商的女儿。非常熟悉节目的朋友。非常熟悉《历史的其余部分》的朋友。当我们做节目时——这对许多听众来说可能难以理解——我们做了一期关于“历史版恋爱岛”的节目，她在节目中和犹大·加略人勾搭上了。我想这对那个男人来说太沉重了。是的，我想也是。
I think she actually dumped Jimmy Carter for Judas Ascarriot in Love Island. Anyway, that will be babbled to a lot of listeners. To get back to the history, Marcia is Wilson's political secretary, and she has this extraordinary and inexplicable hold over him. So every now and again, she would lift up her handbag, point to her handbag, and say to his other at aides, whom she hated, One call to the Daily Mail and he will be finished. I will destroy him.
我想她在“恋爱岛”里为了犹大·加略人甩了吉米·卡特。总之，这对很多听众来说都是胡言乱语。回到历史，玛西娅是威尔逊的政治秘书，她对他有一种非同寻常且无法解释的控制力。所以每隔一段时间，她就会提起她的手提包，指着手提包，对她讨厌的其他助手说：“给《每日邮报》打一个电话，他就完了。我会毁了他。”
What do you think is in her handbag? Nothing. I think it's just... Nothing. It's just... She's just making it out. She knows stuff. She knows stuff.
你觉得她的手提包里有什么？什么都没有。我想那只是……什么都没有。她只是……她在虚张声势。她知道一些事情。她知道一些事情。
And one of the things she knows, she supposedly said to Wilson's wife, Mary, I have only one thing to say to you. I went to bed with your husband six times in 1956 and it was not satisfactory. Which, as we said before, it's not a sentence that any, you know, wife ever wants to hear, I think. But she has this inext... you know, whatever the truth of this, she has this extraordinary power over Wilson. So at one point Donahue's, I think it's either Donahue or Haynes describes his prime minister, it's kind of 1975.
其中一件事是，据说她对威尔逊的妻子玛丽说：“我只有一件事要对你说。我在1956年和你丈夫睡过六次，而且那并不令人满意。”正如我们之前所说，这不是任何妻子想听到的句子。但她有这种……无论真相如何，她对威尔逊有这种非同寻常的权力。所以有一次多纳休——我想是多纳休或海恩斯——描述他的首相，那是1975年左右。
She has banned him from having lunch with his advisors, so he has to have lunch on his own. And at one point he escapes her clutches. And she has ordered him to go to a reception at the House of Lords, and he escapes from the House of Lords and bunks off that number 10. The Callum, our new Supremo, will have to prepare his bleeper because he's supposed. escapes back to number 10. She follows him back. And he's there. She finds him with all his advice and civil service.
她禁止他与顾问共进午餐，所以他必须独自吃午餐。有一次他逃出了她的魔掌。她命令他去参加上议院的一个招待会，他从上议院逃跑了，溜回了唐宁街10号。卡勒姆，我们的新最高统帅，将不得不准备好他的寻呼机，因为他应该……逃回了10号。她跟着他回去了。他在那里。她发现他和所有的顾问及公务员在一起。
And she shouts at him, you little, you come back with me at once. Do you think there's a kind of Dr. Johnson and Mrs. Thraild dynamic? I think that definitely is. Yeah. There is a, I think he quite enjoys it. It's some weird. It likes being bossed around by a powerful woman. At some weird level.
她对他大喊：“你这个小东西，马上跟我回去。”你认为这是一种约翰逊博士和特雷尔夫人式的动态吗？我认为绝对是。是的。有一种……我想他很享受。这很奇怪。他喜欢被一个强大的女人指挥。在某种奇怪的层面上。
Yeah. Now, as we discussed before, Wilson's other aids genuinely contemplates. murdering her. Just say that again. People may have missed it. Say it again. They genuinely contemplated murdering her. So Wilson's doctor,
是的。现在，正如我们之前讨论过的，威尔逊的其他助手真的考虑过谋杀她。再说一遍。人们可能错过了。再说一遍。他们真的考虑过谋杀她。所以威尔逊的医生，
Lord Stone, went to Haynes and Donahue and said, look, I can dispose of her and I will sign the death certificate nobody will ever know. And he says it would be a mercy,
斯通勋爵，去找海恩斯和多纳休说：“听着，我可以处理掉她，我会签死亡证明，没人会知道。”他说这是一种仁慈，
didn't he? Like putting an animal, a mad dog down. Well, I think that's actually what Jeremy Thorpe said of Norman Scott. Oh,
不是吗？就像把一只动物，一只疯狗安乐死一样。嗯，我想那实际上是杰里米·索普对诺曼·斯科特说的话。哦，
I'm getting muddle. They're all murdering each other. We're now conflating a lot of different 70 scandals. we should be coming to Jeremy Thorpe, I'm happy to say later on. Now there's a, since the 1974 series that we did in 2024, there's been an exciting development in the case because we now know that, according to Joe Haynes, that Wilson was also having
我搞混了。他们都在互相谋杀。我们现在把很多不同的70年代丑闻混在一起了。我很高兴地说，我们稍后会谈到杰里米·索普。现在，自从我们在2024年制作1974年系列节目以来，案件有了令人兴奋的进展，因为我们现在知道，根据乔·海恩斯的说法，威尔逊还与他的副新闻秘书珍妮特·休利特·戴维斯有某种关系，
some kind of relationship with his deputy press secretary, Janet Hewlett Davis, who was 22 years, his junior. There is some doubt about how physical this relationship was, whether maybe it was just a kind of emotional relationship. a very intense friendship. But she would definitely spend evenings with him, Janet Hewlett-Davis. And so I think this is clearly contributing to Marcia's fury, her general fury throughout this story. As we go through the political narrative in today's episode and indeed next week's episode,
她比他小22岁。关于这种关系的身体接触程度，或者这是否只是一种情感关系，存在一些疑问。一种非常强烈的友谊。但她确实会和他共度夜晚，珍妮特·休利特·戴维斯。所以我认为这显然加剧了玛西娅的愤怒，她在整个故事中表现出的普遍愤怒。当我们浏览今天这一集以及下周那一集的政治叙事时，
you have to assume that in the background, there's enormous amounts of drinking, there's a lot of squabbling and probably bed-hopping of sort of farcical proportions going on. It is like a 1970s bedroom fast. isn't it? Yeah. I mean, to give you a sense, I mean, we're not going to get into all the lunch negotiations,
你必须假设在背景中，有大量的饮酒，有很多争吵，可能还有闹剧般比例的换床行为。这就像一部1970年代的卧室闹剧，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，给你一个概念，我的意思是，我们不会深入探讨所有的午餐谈判，
which are just insane, but as late as May 1975, they are still negotiating what Donahue calls, quote, a compromise package in which Marcia will allow the Prime Minister
那些谈判简直疯狂，但直到1975年5月，他们仍在谈判多纳休所说的“妥协方案”，玛西娅将允许首相
to have lunch with his advisors as long as it is not the number 10 dining room. I mean, negotiating with the trade unions must seem picnic compared to all this.
与他的顾问共进午餐，只要不是在10号的餐厅里。我的意思是，与工会谈判相比，这一切简直是小菜一碟。
Exactly. So this is going on. But the other thing, of course, is the state of the nation, which is contributing to the pressure on Wilson. Because thanks to Ted Heath having inflated the economy and then the 1973 oil shock, inflation has gone through the roof. It is now hurtling towards 25%.
完全正确。所以这一切都在发生。但另一件事当然是国情，这加剧了威尔逊的压力。因为多亏了泰德·希思推高了经济，然后是1973年的石油危机，通货膨胀已经飙升。现在正向25%冲刺。
And on top of that, public borrowing is totally and utterly out of control because during the course of 1974, Wilson's Chancellor, Dennis Healy, has spent very recklessly. Basically, he blew a lot of, of money on pensions and sort of giveaways to help Labor win the next election in October, which was very cany politically, but not terribly cany economically, because the result was that in cash terms, public spending went up in 1974 by 35%.
最重要的是，公共借贷完全失控了，因为在1974年期间，威尔逊的财政大臣丹尼斯·希利花钱非常鲁莽。基本上，他为了帮助工党在10月赢得下一次大选，在养老金和各种赠品上挥霍了大量资金，这在政治上非常精明，但在经济上却不怎么精明，因为结果是公共支出在1974年以现金计算增长了35%。
Now, some of this was funded by very high taxes on the rich. So to remind people, Labor in 74 put the top rate of income tax up to 80,000. and the top rate of tax on investments went up to 98%. But that's still not enough to generate the cash they need. So after the October election, the Treasury presented Dennis Healy, the Chancellor, with the bill. Britain was going to have to borrow. They said twice as much as expected, £6 billion in 74,75, and almost 9 billion in 75. 76. Now, amidst all this, business confidence is absolutely tanked. The stock market is in meltdown.
现在，其中一些资金是通过对富人征收高额税款来筹集的。提醒一下大家，工党在74年将最高所得税率提高到了80%，投资税最高税率提高到了98%。但这仍然不足以产生他们需要的现金。所以在10月大选后，财政部向财政大臣丹尼斯·希利提交了账单。英国将不得不借款。他们说比预期的多两倍，74-75年度借款60亿英镑，75-76年度借款近90亿英镑。现在，在这一切之中，商业信心完全崩溃了。股市陷入了混乱。
The Financial Magazine International Insider says Britain is fast turning into a borrower to be classed alongside an underdeveloped country, which is not a good thing to hear. And when you get to the beginning of 1975, Wilson's advisors in Downing Street are at him constantly, and they are saying there was going to be, quote, a terrible crisis unless we change course and get a grip on the economy. We're completely out of control. We're sort of, we're basically Argentina is what we are. But you mentioned it already. Wilson only has a three-seat majority in the House of Commons. He has a lot of left-wing MPs who don't like the thought of any form of cuts. And he has a very left-wing manifesto. This is a kind of enduring theme, isn't it, with Labour governments? Is that the Prime Minister is kind of forced by circumstance or whatever or the economy or whatever, to move rightwards.
财经杂志《国际内部人士》称，英国正迅速变成一个被归类为不发达国家的借款国，这可不是什么好消息。当你进入1975年初时，威尔逊在唐宁街的顾问们不断地催促他，他们说除非我们改变方针并控制住经济，否则将会出现“可怕的危机”。我们完全失控了。我们有点……我们基本上就是阿根廷。但你已经提到了。威尔逊在下议院只有三个席位的多数。他有很多左翼议员，他们不喜欢任何形式的削减。他有一个非常左翼的竞选纲领。这是一个持久的主题，不是吗，工党政府？就是首相因为环境、经济或其他原因被迫向右转。
And MPs on the backbenches, who are not in the government, tend to be more left-wing. And if there's a small majority, or indeed in Kirstama's case, even they've got a massive majority, they then create trouble. Well, you know what? I was thinking about the Kirste-Stama parallel. Howard Wilson has a much worse inheritance than Kirstama. I mean, far worse. And, you know, Howard Wilson has only a majority of three, whereas Kirstama's got a majority
而不在政府中的后座议员往往更左倾。如果多数席位很小，或者实际上在基尔·斯塔默的情况下，即使他们有巨大的多数，他们也会制造麻烦。嗯，你知道吗？我一直在思考基尔·斯塔默的平行案例。哈罗德·威尔逊的遗产比基尔·斯塔默糟糕得多。我的意思是，糟糕得多。而且，你知道，哈罗德·威尔逊只有三个席位的多数，而基尔·斯塔默有
of about 500 or something, a massive majority. Wilson is a much more adept political operator than Kirstarmer is. But even he, you know, he is trapped. And he's trapped in part. You mentioned the manifesto. I mean, you might well think, who cares about manifestos, the public never read them. But political people in this era care an enormous amount. And as odd as it may seem to a lot of listeners, especially outside Britain, in these days, in the 1970s, you don't choose your own manifesto.
大约500个席位，巨大的多数。威尔逊是一个比基尔·斯塔默更娴熟的政治操作者。但即使是他，你知道，他也陷入了困境。他被困住了，部分原因是你提到的竞选纲领。我的意思是，你可能很想知道，谁在乎竞选纲领，公众从不阅读它们。但这个时代的政治人物非常在乎。而且，尽管对许多听众来说可能很奇怪，特别是在英国以外，在这些日子里，在1970年代，你不能选择自己的竞选纲领。
It's imposed on you if you're in the Labour Party by your own activists. So the activists have basically written the manifesto and it calls for, and I quote, a fundamental and irreversible shift in the balance of power and wealth in favour of working people and their families. So it's the most radical manifesto with which Labour have come to power in generations. The commitments include a referendum on pulling out of the European community,
如果你在工党，它是由你自己的活动家强加给你的。所以活动家们基本上写了竞选纲领，它呼吁——我引用——“在平衡工薪阶层及其家庭的权力和财富方面，进行根本性和不可逆转的转变”。所以这是工党几代人以来上台时最激进的竞选纲领。承诺包括就退出欧洲共同体进行公投，
a massive expansion of state intervention, the creation of a new National Enterprise Board to take over private firms in the public interest, all of this stuff which we will come on to later. The most obvious aspect of the manifesto is they're committed to a relationship with the unions, which they call the social contract. It has nothing to do, by the way, with Jean-Jacques Rousseau. I mean, they just like the name.
大规模扩大国家干预，建立一个新的国家企业委员会以公共利益接管私营企业，所有这些我们稍后会谈到的内容。竞选纲领最明显的方面是他们致力于与工会建立一种关系，他们称之为“社会契约”。顺便说一句，这与让-雅克·卢梭毫无关系。我的意思是，他们只是喜欢这个名字。
So under the social contract, the government will basically give the unions unprecedented rights and powers. They'll give them lots of new legislation on employment protections and strikers rights and all this kind of thing. basically they'll tick off the union's wish list. And in return, the unions will keep their pay demands in line with the cost of living. And when Labor gets in, they absolutely do deliver on the first bit. Wilson's employment secretary, Michael Foote, pushes through five bills in two years
所以根据社会契约，政府基本上会给予工会前所未有的权利和权力。他们会给他们许多关于就业保护和罢工权利等方面的立法。基本上他们会满足工会的愿望清单。作为回报，工会将把他们的工资要求与生活成本挂钩。当工党上台时，他们确实兑现了第一部分。威尔逊的就业大臣迈克尔·富特在两年内通过了五项法案，
to strengthen workers' rights and union powers. So they've delivered. The problem is the union leaders can't really deliver on their end of the bargain because they're under massive pressure from their members in an age of inflation. and because the unions are very competitive. They're always fighting each other. They're always trying to outflank each other and get a better deal. Which is ironic, isn't it?
以加强工人的权利和工会的权力。所以他们兑现了。问题是工会领导人无法真正兑现他们的承诺，因为在通货膨胀的时代，他们承受着来自成员的巨大压力，而且因为工会之间竞争非常激烈。他们总是互相争斗。他们总是试图互相超越以获得更好的交易。这很讽刺，不是吗？
Well, yeah, I guess so, yeah. This competition is what Mrs. Satchett is all about. Well, this is what foreign observers, like Helmut Schmidt, the West German Chancellor, when he came to Britain, and he came to Britain to address the Labour Party conference in 1974. And he would say, you know, why have you got so many trade unions? Mental. Like in Germany, we have only a few trade unions that work very closely with the government,
嗯，是的，我想是吧。这种竞争正是撒切尔夫人所反对的。嗯，这就是外国观察家，比如西德总理赫尔穆特·施密特，当他来到英国时，他来到英国是为了在1974年的工党大会上发表演讲。他会说，你知道，为什么你们有这么多工会？疯了。就像在德国，我们只有几个与政府密切合作的工会，
and it's all fine. you have hundreds of trade unions and they're all squabbling the whole time and because of that they're always trying to outflank each other to get a better deal so you just get this ratchet effect where you're giving away ever better deals anyway. As a result of this
一切都很好。你们有数百个工会，他们一直在争吵，正因为如此，他们总是试图互相超越以获得更好的交易，所以你只会得到这种棘轮效应，你给出的交易越来越好。总之，由于这个原因，
throughout 1974 and 1975 the Wilson government are hurling money around so they're giving these big paying greases 30% to the railwaymen 31% to the power workers 32% to the civil servants 35% to the doctors as the postman's leader, Tom Jackson said,
在整个1974年和1975年，威尔逊政府一直在到处撒钱，所以他们给出了这些大幅加薪：铁路工人30%，电力工人31%，公务员32%，医生35%。正如邮递员领袖汤姆·杰克逊所说，
it was as though we had found a gigantic Las Vegas slot machine that had suddenly got stuck in favour of the customer. So that's the union leader saying that. Yeah, and in fact, so by the spring of 1975, prices in Britain are rising five times faster than in any other European country. If you're in a powerful union, this is kind of all right because your union will probably have got you a 35% pay increase.
“就好像我们发现了一台巨大的拉斯维加斯老虎机，它突然卡在了有利于顾客的位置。”所以那是工会领袖说的。是的，事实上，到1975年春天，英国的价格上涨速度比其他任何欧洲国家快五倍。如果你在一个强大的工会里，这还算可以，因为你的工会可能会为你争取到35%的加薪，
so you can afford your tins of beans or whatever. If you're not in a powerful union, if you're self-employed, if you are very young, if you are old, if you're living on a pension, if you live on your savings, this is a nightmare. And we'll talk about this a little bit more next week. So faced with all this, the mood at the top is very gloomy. At the end of 1974, Wilson's Cabinet had an away day at Chequers, the Prime Minister's Country House. and they basically, you know, you can read all the accounts in their diaries,
所以你买得起你的豆子罐头什么的。如果你不在一个强大的工会里，如果你是自雇人士，如果你非常年轻，如果你年老，如果你靠养老金生活，如果你靠积蓄生活，这就是一场噩梦。下周我们会多谈谈这一点。所以面对这一切，高层的气氛非常阴郁。1974年底，威尔逊的内阁在首相的乡村别墅契克斯举行了一次务虚会，他们基本上，你知道，你可以在他们的日记中读到所有的记录，
they basically say they have no idea what to do. They genuinely have no idea what to do. And most famously, his Foreign Secretary Jim Callaghan, who will be playing a big part in this series as it goes on, said to the others, when I'm shaving in the morning, I say to myself that if I were a young man, I would emigrate. And obviously this is a terrible tone
他们基本上说他们不知道该怎么办。他们真的不知道该怎么办。最著名的是，他的外交大臣吉姆·卡拉汉（随着节目的进行，他将在本系列中扮演重要角色）对其他人说：“我早上刮胡子时对自己说，如果我是一个年轻人，我会移民。”显然这是一个可怕的基调，
for the people at the top of your society to be striking. And actually a lot of people do emigrate. in 1975 the population of Britain fell for the first time since records began and then it fell again in 1976 and again in 1977 basically because so many people are getting out to New Zealand, Australia, South Africa, Canada, whatever. And so what is this doing for Britain's international standing? Well, I'll quote Henry Kissinger. We have an Oval Office transcript from January 1975.
对于你社会高层的人来说。实际上很多人确实移民了。1975年，英国人口自记录开始以来首次下降，然后在1976年再次下降，1977年又下降，基本上是因为很多人去了新西兰、澳大利亚、南非、加拿大等等。那么这对英国的国际地位有什么影响呢？嗯，我引用亨利·基辛格的话。我们有一份1975年1月的椭圆形办公室记录。
Henry Kissinger is talking to Gerald Ford, President Ford, and he says, Britain is a tragedy. It has sunk to begging, borrowing. stealing until North Sea oil comes in that Britain has become such a scrounger is a disgrace. I feel that's sad. I like Britain and I don't like to see it being slagged off in the Oval Office. Wall Street Journal three months later.
亨利·基辛格正在与杰拉尔德·福特总统交谈，他说：“英国是一场悲剧。它已经沦落到乞讨、借贷、偷窃，直到北海石油开采出来。英国变得如此像个乞丐，真是一种耻辱。”我觉得这很悲哀。我喜欢英国，我不喜欢看到它在椭圆形办公室里被诋毁。《华尔街日报》三个月后说，
Britain is sinking, it says. Labour are heading for a policy of total confiscation so anybody with any money should get it out of the country. Goodbye, Great Britain. It was nice knowing you. And actually, we haven't even mentioned Northern Ireland. I mean, this is now a frozen confrontation. We'll talk about this a tiny bit more next week.
“英国正在下沉，”它说。“工党正走向全面没收的政策，所以任何有钱的人都应该把它带出这个国家。再见，大英帝国。很高兴认识你。”而且，我们甚至还没提到北爱尔兰。我的意思是，这现在是一个冻结的对抗。下周我们会多谈一点。
The province has now been governed from Westminster, but hundreds of people are dying every year. Again, terrible publicity for Britain, especially in America. So would you say things are worse then than they are now? Oh, yeah. Unquestionably worse then. So this is cheering people up, actually. I like to cheer people up. We don't have hundreds of people dying in terrorist attacks. And the economy's not as bad?
该省现在由威斯敏斯特管理，但每年都有数百人死亡。同样，这对英国来说是可怕的宣传，特别是在美国。那么你会说当时的情况比现在更糟吗？哦，是的。毫无疑问当时更糟。所以这实际上是在让人们振作起来。我喜欢让人们振作起来。我们现在没有数百人在恐怖袭击中丧生。而且经济也没有那么糟糕？
The economy is utterly moribund. But what's inflation now? 3% or something? What was inflation then? 25%. Mind you, we are recording this in the middle of the Iran War, so God knows what will have happened
经济完全处于停滞状态。但现在的通货膨胀率是多少？3%左右？当时通货膨胀率是多少？25%。话虽如此，我们是在伊朗战争期间录制节目的，所以天知道到节目播出时会发生什么。
by the time this goes out. Yeah, but the difference is that's an external shock. I mean, external shock is always bad for you, whereas this at this point has become endemic. Everybody else is basically recovering from the after effects
是的，但区别在于那是外部冲击。我的意思是，外部冲击对你来说总是坏事，而这一点在此时已经变得地方性了。其他人基本上都在从1973年石油危机的余波中恢复过来。英国只是越来越深地陷入泥潭，我想。而且，基尔·斯塔默的行为肯定不像哈罗德·威尔逊那么滑稽，对吧？
of the 1973 through all crisis. Britain is just plunging deeper and deeper into the morass, I suppose. Also, Kirstama is not behaving quite as ludicously as Harold Wilson, surely.
我的意思是，如果他那样做，我几乎会感到振奋。因为他太无聊了。所以说到哈罗德·威尔逊，我们来到1975年春天。他的顾问们拼命乞求他采取行动对抗通货膨胀，但他什么也没做，
I mean, I would almost be heartened if he were. because he's so boring. So talking of Harold Wilson, we come to the spring of 1975. His advisors are desperately begging him to take action against inflation, but he doesn't do anything about it
因为基本上他有这个微小的多数，他不想冒犯左翼。令人惊奇的是，工会领导人自己现在也说这必须改变。所以一些工会领导人去找工会大会主席伦·默里，他们说，
because basically he's got this tiny majority, he doesn't want to offend the left. And the amazing thing about this is the trade union leaders themselves now are saying this has got to change. So some of the trade union leaders go to the head of the trade union Congress, Len Murray, and they say,
“我引用，我们不能再这样下去了。你知道，我必须不断要求为我的成员争取更好的交易。然而，在某个时候，政府需要说不。理想情况下，他们不会对我说不，但他们不应该对我的其他领导人说不，他们应该，你知道，我们应该解决这个问题。这太疯狂了。”而且在这一切之上，还有一个进一步的转折，这把我们带回了巴兹尔和德国人，因为这个转折是欧洲。两年来，英国一直是欧洲共同体的成员，现在威尔逊想给人们机会
and I quote, we can't go on like this. You know, I have to keep asking for a better deal for my members. However, at some point the government needs to say no. Ideally, they won't say no to me, but they shouldn't say no to some of my fellow leaders and they should, you know, we should sort something out. This is madness. And then on top of all this, there is a further twist and this takes us back to Basil and the Germans, because this twist is Europe. For two years, Britain has been a member of the European community and now Wilson wants to give people the chance to
退出来，进行一次脱欧公投。为了解释他为什么要这样做，我们必须回到我们在《历史的其余部分》中从未谈论过的事情。所以我们已经做了几百集节目，但我们从未做过英国和欧洲。我想是因为有一种普遍的感觉，不是吗，汤姆，你可能不同意我的看法，但我认为你不会，即关于英国和欧洲共同体的主题无聊得令人难以置信。确实很无聊，是的。你不认为人们是这么想的吗？看，我认为，这是脱欧的一个被低估的因素，如果你住在卢森堡，你想到欧盟，你的心就会歌唱。你的脚步会轻快起来。你会想到一个和平的新时代。而在英国，有人向你提到欧盟，你
come out, a Brexit referendum. And to explain why he's doing this, we have to go back to something we've actually never talked about in the rest of history. So we've done however many hundred episodes, but we've never done Britain and Europe. I think because there's a general sense, isn't that Tom, you might disagree with me about this, but I don't think you will, that the subject of Britain and the European community is unbelievably boring. It's quite boring, yes. Do you not think people think that? See, I think, which is one thing, an underappreciated element of Brexit, that if you live in Luxembourg and you think about the European Union, your heart sings. There's a spring in your step. You think of a new age of peace. Whereas in Britain, someone mentions to you the EU and you
就会想到关于香肠大小的规定。确实会。是的，绝对。羊肉检查之类的东西。完全正确。本质上很枯燥，除非你是一只羊，当然。好吧，我们会拆解这一点，因为让我们谈谈英国和欧洲。所以如果你回到它的起源，1957年，六个国家签署了《罗马条约》以建立欧洲经济共同体，那是建立更紧密联盟计划的第一步。这都是关于煤炭和钢铁的，不是吗？
think of regulations about the size of sausages. You do. Yeah, absolutely. Checks on lamb, that kind of thing. Exactly. Just intrinsically dull, unless you're a lamb, of course. Well, we will unpack this, because let's talk about Britain and Europe. So if you go back to the origins of it, in 1957, six countries signed the Treaty of Rome to build the European Economic Community and that was the first step in this project to build ever closer Union. It's all about coal and steel, isn't it?
最初是煤炭和钢铁，欧洲煤炭和钢铁共同体。但基本上，这是一个“传送带”的想法。你知道，我们将缓慢但稳步地走向更大的联盟。这意味着欧洲将永远不会再有战争，我们将变得更富有，我们将更快乐，我们将成为朋友，
It was coal and steel originally, the European coal and steel community. But basically, it was a conveyabout idea. You know, we'll move slowly but steadily towards greater Union. This will mean there'll never be another war in Europe and we'll all be richer and we'll be happier and we'll be friends
那将是伟大的。但从伦敦的角度来看，这是给失败者准备的东西，不是吗？因为要么是那些被盟军击败的人，要么是被德国人击败的人，或者是法西斯分子。这就是克莱门特·艾德礼在被问及此事时所说的。他说：“你觉得怎么样？”他说：“嗯，最近我们不得不阻止六个国家中的两个基本上杀掉其他四个国家的所有人。”
and it'll be great. But seen from London, it's something for losers, isn't it? Because it's either people who've been defeated by the Allies or people who've been defeated by the Germans or been fascist. This is what Clement Attlee said when he was asked about it. He said, what do you think about? And he said, well, very recently we had to stop two of the six countries from basically killing everybody in the other four.
“我们为什么要和他们搅在一起？”实际上，我不认为有任何英国会早早加入的剧本。首先，英国在1950年代拥有一个帝国。所以，你知道，那是每个人都感兴趣的。政治家们对加拿大、澳大利亚或中东发生的事情比对比利时、卢森堡或意大利发生的事情更感兴趣。这就是戴高乐著名的说法，不是吗？英国的视野是……
Why would we get involved with them? And actually, I don't think there's any scenario in which Britain would have joined early on. First of all, Britain has an empire in the 1950s. So, you know, that's what everybody's interested in. Politicians are much more interested in what's going on Canada or Australia or the Middle East than they are in what's going on in Belgium, Luxembourg or Italy. And this is what DeGaultz famously says, isn't it? That Britain's horizons are...
全球性的。是的，大西洋的。她看向大海。完全正确。很多人在英国自己也这么想。我的意思是，很多出口商认为他们正在向澳大利亚或加拿大销售商品。他们并不真的想向卢森堡销售商品。在左翼，工党和工会，在这一点上普遍认为欧洲是一个资本主义基督教民主党的阴谋。
Global. Yeah, an Atlantic. She looks to the sea. Exactly. And lots of people think that in Britain themselves. I mean, lots of exporters think that they're selling goods to Australia or to Canada. They don't really want to sell goods to Luxembourg. On the left, the Labour Party and the trade unions, generally at this point, think of Europe as a capitalist Christian Democrat plot.
全球化。没错，大西洋。她面向海洋。确实如此。许多英国人自己也这么认为。我的意思是，很多出口商认为他们是在向澳大利亚或加拿大销售商品。他们并不真的想把商品卖给卢森堡。在左翼方面，工党和工会通常在这一点上认为欧洲是一个资本主义基督教民主党的阴谋。
These are all a load of kind of weird Italians with kind of thin glasses who are rigging elections to stop socialists winning. And they don't like socialism. Why on earth would we get into bed with these people? They're bad people. And what's worse, they're all Catholics. And there's loads of people in the Labour Party and the trade unions. who are kind of low church Protestants. And they were like, why would we get into bed with these people?
这些人全是一群戴着细框眼镜、看起来怪怪的意大利人，他们操纵选举以阻止社会主义者获胜。他们不喜欢社会主义。我们到底为什么要和这些人同流合污？他们是坏人。更糟糕的是，他们全是天主教徒。工党和工会里有很多人是低教会派的新教徒。他们当时的想法是，我们为什么要和这些人同流合污？
They're the worst people. And then generally the public at large, for completely obvious cultural and historic reasons, just do not think of themselves as continental Europeans. In recent years, historians have written excellent books saying, this is nonsense. Britain was always part of Europe, you know, the war of the whatever succession,
他们是最糟糕的人。而且，总的来说，出于完全显而易见的文化和历史原因，广大公众根本不认为自己是欧洲大陆人。近年来，历史学家写了出色的著作说，这纯属无稽之谈。英国一直都是欧洲的一部分，你知道的，什么王位继承战争，
William Lev Orange, all of this kind of thing. That's all fine. But the public just don't want to know that at this point, they just don't think, you know, you see so many quotes in sort of post-war Britain. Well, we're not like them. We're not like the French and the Germans. We've always stood alone, you know, all that kind of thing. And you can't persuade people by writing academic monographs. It's more deep-seated than that.
威廉三世（奥兰治亲王），所有这些事情。这都没问题。但公众在这一点上就是不想知道，他们就是不这么想，你知道，你在战后英国的各种言论中看到了很多这样的观点。嗯，我们和他们不一样。我们不像法国人和德国人。我们一直都是孤军奋战，你知道，诸如此类。你不能通过写学术专著来说服人们。这比那更根深蒂固。
I mean, people have lived through two wars in which the continent was nothing but trouble. I mean, that would be one way you could frame it. Yeah. I think that's exactly how people think. They think we've fought two wars against these people. They're terrible people. why would we get involved with them? We don't want to have anything to do with it.
我的意思是，人们经历过两次战争，而欧洲大陆除了麻烦什么也没带来。我的意思是，这是一种你可以用来解读的方式。是的。我认为这正是人们的想法。他们认为我们和这些人打过两场战争。他们是可怕的人。我们为什么要卷入其中？我们不想和它有任何瓜葛。
Now, by the early 60s, elite opinion had begun to shift. The empire had gone. The Suez crisis had happened, which very much damaged the relationship with America. And as we talked about, last time, the British economy is performing really badly compared with France or Germany or Italy or whatever. And actually, a lot of people at the top in Westminster in the media grudgingly change their minds. Maybe it would be good to sell our products to the Europeans. after all. So, 1961, Harold McMillan, Tory Prime Minister, applied to join, and General de Gaulle
到了60年代初，精英阶层的观点开始转变。帝国已经不复存在。苏伊士运河危机发生了，这极大地损害了与美国的关系。正如我们上次谈到的，与法国、德国或意大利等国相比，英国经济表现非常糟糕。事实上，威斯敏斯特和媒体的高层中有许多人勉强改变了主意。也许把我们的产品卖给欧洲人确实是件好事。所以，1961年，保守党首相哈罗德·麦克米伦申请加入，而戴高乐将军
vetoed it in January 63. He said, come on, you're not Europeans. You're always going on about your Commonwealth and the America and, yeah, the open sea, all of that stuff. I've had, I'm sick of hearing about Nelson. You can't join. And so they, he rejects it. So, no pleur-a-pain my lord. He says to, don't cry, my lord, he says to, I mean, that's, it's very ungrateful. grateful from de Gaulle, given that we bailed him out. I know. But I kind of respect him for it, though. You know, that's what the French do very well.
在63年1月否决了它。他说，得了吧，你们不是欧洲人。你们总是喋喋不休地谈论你们的英联邦、美国，还有，是的，广阔的海洋，所有这些东西。我受够了听关于纳尔逊的事。你们不能加入。于是他们，他拒绝了。所以，没有“请，我的大人”。他对他说，别哭，我的大人，他对他说，我的意思是，这，这非常忘恩负义。戴高乐这样做非常忘恩负义，考虑到我们曾救过他。我知道。但我还是有点尊重他。你知道，这就是法国人非常擅长的事情。
The knife in their back. The chief British negotiator was a young, a young Turk, a thrusting young Turk called Ted Heath. And Ted Heath said, we in Britain are a part of Europe by geography, tradition, history, culture and civilization. I mean, he had been to the Nuremberg rallies, right? I mean, he'd seen what could go wrong in Europe. Do you not recall he had shaken hands with Himmler?
背后捅刀子。英国首席谈判代表是一位年轻的、充满干劲的“少壮派”，名叫泰德·希思。泰德·希思说，我们英国在地理、传统、历史、文化和文明上都是欧洲的一部分。我的意思是，他去过纽伦堡集会，对吧？我的意思是，他见过欧洲可能出什么问题。你不记得他曾与希姆莱握过手吗？
Yeah. Was disappointed by Himmler's handshake. Yeah. And then he'd fought in the Second World War. And, yeah, Heath is basically the one man in Britain or one of a very small group of people who are passionate Europhiles. But most people aren't. In 1967, Harold Wilson, Labour, made another very tentative approach, and DeGle rejected it again. No way.
是的。对希姆莱的握手感到失望。是的。然后他参加了第二次世界大战。而且，是的，希思基本上是英国唯一一个，或者极少数热情的亲欧派之一。但大多数人不是。1967年，工党的哈罗德·威尔逊又进行了一次非常试探性的接触，戴高乐再次拒绝了。没门。
I'm not even going to contemplate it. Now, there are two telling things about these first bids. First of all, neither of them was very popular with the public. So when people were asked, they were either utterly indifferent or hostile. And the second thing, I think, is really important. And explains actually how you got to Brexit in 2016. Both of them were basically born out of weakness and desperation and not enthusiasm. British governments did not try to join Europe because they loved Europe.
我甚至不会考虑它。现在，关于这最初的两次申入，有两件事很能说明问题。首先，这两次申入在公众中都不太受欢迎。所以当人们被问及时，他们要么完全漠不关心，要么充满敌意。第二件事，我认为非常重要。并且实际上解释了你是如何在2016年走到脱欧这一步的。这两次申入基本上都源于软弱和绝望，而不是热情。英国政府试图加入欧洲并不是因为他们热爱欧洲。
They were trying to join Europe basically because they'd run out of other options and this was the last card in the deck. And it's very grudging. It's a kind of getting into bed with Luxembourg feels like the last thing, you know, you want to do, but they have to do it. Anyway, Heath, who's the one person who really is passionate about it, finally gets Britain through the door, and in January 73, Britain joins the European economic community, which at the time was known in Britain as the common market. The thing is that by this point, a lot of time has gone by, so the rules are already established. And they've been established by governments that have, for instance, lots of farmers. Yeah.
他们试图加入欧洲基本上是因为他们已经别无选择，这是最后一张牌。而且非常勉强。这就像是与卢森堡同流合污，感觉是你想做的最后一件事，但他们不得不这样做。总之，希思，那个真正对此充满热情的人，最终让英国跨过了门槛，1973年1月，英国加入了欧洲经济共同体，当时在英国被称为“共同市场”。问题是，到这个时候，已经过去很长时间了，所以规则已经确立。而且它们是由那些拥有大量农民的政府确立的。是的。
Who have their own take that aren't necessarily advantageous for British farmers. Exactly. So Britain had to swallow 13,000 pages of European enactments about farming and fishing
他们有自己的主张，这对英国农民来说未必有利。没错。所以英国不得不吞下13000页关于农业和渔业的欧洲法令
and all these kinds of things. And this becomes this running sore. So basically nobody in Britain likes having to swallow the rules and they complain about it consistently for the next 50 years or whatever it is. Dominic, am I right
以及所有这些事情。这成了心头大患。所以基本上英国没人喜欢不得不吞下这些规则，并且在接下来的50年左右的时间里，他们一直在抱怨。多米尼克，我说的对吗？
that because we invented cricket, we therefore follow the laws. Whereas sneaky continental types don't. Nigel Faradj joins us on the show. Great time on the show. I'm just asking. Is that because that is, that has been a prevailing stereotype. That is the perception. That is the perception. Okay. So a couple of observations on the politics of it. At this point it is seen primarily as a conservative project. So it's Heath's project. There are some Tory rebels, about 40 of them, who are led by Enoch Powell, who think that Europe will undermine British sovereignty, but they are definitely a minority.
因为我们发明了板球，所以我们遵守规则。而狡猾的欧洲大陆人却不遵守。奈杰尔·法拉奇加入了我们的节目。节目时间很棒。我只是问问。这是因为那是一个普遍的刻板印象吗？那是人们的看法。那是人们的看法。好吧。那么关于它的政治有几点观察。在这一点上，它主要被视为一个保守党项目。所以这是希思的项目。有一些保守党叛逆者，大约40人，由伊诺克·鲍威尔领导，他们认为欧洲会破坏英国的主权，但他们绝对是少数。
Heath never admits that there's a trade-off between the benefits of joining the common market and the obvious sort of downsides, which are that obviously it will affect British sovereignty because European laws will take precedence over British ones. and Dennis Healy, Labour Chancellor, who had been at university with Ted Heath, he said later, if Heath had been honest about it, he would not have got it through. Heath did what he had to do, smart politics. He downplayed the democratic implications of European membership because he knew that the British people would have a massive hissy fit if they found out that European laws took precedence. And actually that brings us to this question of the great British public.
希思从未承认加入共同市场的利益与明显的弊端之间存在权衡，弊端显然是它会影响英国主权，因为欧洲法律将优先于英国法律。而工党财政大臣丹尼斯·希利，曾与泰德·希思在同一所大学，他后来表示，如果希思对此诚实，他就无法通过。希思做了他必须做的事，聪明的政治。他淡化了欧洲成员资格的民主影响，因为他知道如果英国人民发现欧洲法律具有优先权，他们会大发雷霆。事实上，这把我们带到了伟大的英国公众这个问题上。
In some ways, you could say that British people in the 70s are more European than they've ever been. They go on holidays abroad, which they've never done before in any great numbers. They're even little, tiny little things. So I always think a good indicator is wine drinking. People didn't drink wine at all, really. I mean, about something like 59% of people in the 1950s never drank wine in the course of a year. Because they're drinking beer. Because they're drinking beer.
在某些方面，你可以说70年代的英国人比以往任何时候都更像欧洲人。他们去国外度假，这是他们以前从未大规模做过的。甚至是一些微小的细节。所以我一直认为一个很好的指标是饮酒。人们根本不喝葡萄酒，真的。我的意思是，在20世纪50年代，大约59%的人一年中从不喝葡萄酒。因为他们在喝啤酒。因为他们在喝啤酒。
And it quadruples wine drinking. in the 20 years between 1960 and 1980. And this is, of course, the quintessential sign of continental sophistication. Isn't there another piece of evidence for British engagement with the continent that the Christmas specials of much-loved sitcoms
在1960年到1980年的20年间，葡萄酒消费量翻了两番。这当然是欧洲大陆精致生活的典型标志。关于英国与欧洲大陆的接触，难道没有另一个证据吗？那些深受喜爱的电视情景喜剧的圣诞特辑
always involve the various characters going on an amusing, an amusing holiday jaunt to the Costa del Planca or something? Yeah. Where hilarity ensues. When you see Europe on TV in 1973, exactly. It's either the... Building sites, donkeys, lecherous men, all of that.
总是涉及各种角色去阳光海岸或类似的地方进行一次有趣的、有趣的度假旅行？是的。在那里引发了欢闹。当你在1973年的电视上看到欧洲时，没错。它要么是……建筑工地、驴子、好色的男人，所有这些。
Yeah, it's either salt of the earth Englishmen getting into amusing scrapes and in terrible Costa del Sol resorts. Or it's hard-faced Germans. Of course, yes. Punishing prisoners of war are coldits. Or it's Dad's Army. Or it's the World at War, the documentary series, which I think comes out in 1973. With Sir Lawrence Olivier. Sir Lawrence Olivier, there's a profound obsession, I think, with the Second World War in the 1970s for obvious reasons. I mean, it's very recent, but also it's such a telling contrast with the state of the nation in the 70s.
是的，它要么是脚踏实地的英国人在糟糕的阳光海岸度假胜地陷入有趣的困境。要么是面目可憎的德国人。当然，是的。惩罚战俘的科尔迪茨战俘营。要么是《老爸上战场》。要么是纪录片系列《战争中的世界》，我想是1973年出的。由劳伦斯·奥利弗爵士主持。劳伦斯·奥利弗爵士，我认为在70年代，出于显而易见的原因，人们对第二次世界大战有着深刻的痴迷。我的意思是，它非常近，但也与70年代的国家状况形成了鲜明的对比。
And I think as a result of all that, it's absolutely true that most people do not feel, they do not describe themselves as Europeans. They are very hostile to the idea of European integration. In 1970, when Ted Heath won the election, only one in five people said they supported Britain joining Europe. A year later, 70%, when Heath had launched the application to join, 70% said they were against it. And I think this is a result of Heath's excellent publicity blitz, because he sends girls to beaches. He sends girls to beaches dressed in tight t-shirts that say, say yes to Europe. And they're handing out leaflets that say, Europe is fun. more work and more play too.
我认为由于所有这些原因，绝大多数人确实不认为，他们不把自己描述为欧洲人，这是绝对正确的。他们对欧洲一体化的想法非常敌视。1970年，当泰德·希思赢得选举时，只有五分之一的人表示支持英国加入欧洲。一年后，当希思发起加入申请时，70%的人表示反对。我认为这是希思出色的宣传闪电战的结果，因为他派女孩去海滩。他派女孩去海滩，穿着紧身T恤，上面写着“对欧洲说是”。他们分发传单，上面写着“欧洲很有趣，更多工作，更多娱乐”。
You see, people complain that Kirstama isn't proactive. But there is an example of how he could promote his policies. Well, I actually think Kirstama and Ted Heath, Kirstehrm and Ted Heath, I think, are very similar. They have terrible voices. They are civil servants, basically, aren't they?
你看，人们抱怨基尔·斯塔默不够积极。但这是一个他如何推广其政策的例子。嗯，我实际上认为基尔·斯塔默和泰德·希思，基尔·斯塔默和泰德·希思，我认为，非常相似。他们的声音很糟糕。他们基本上是公务员，不是吗？
They're technocrats. They're not brilliant communicators with the public. Kirstama is more willing to go on about his disadvantaged background. My father was a toolmaker. Ted Heath would never talk about it. So anyway, Ted Heath gets Britain into Europe in January 73 and are people delighted and do they care?
他们是技术官僚。他们不是与公众沟通的天才。基尔·斯塔默更愿意谈论他贫困的背景。我的父亲是一名工具制造工。泰德·希思从不谈论这个。所以总之，泰德·希思在73年1月让英国进入了欧洲，人们高兴吗？他们在乎吗？
Basically no and no. So a survey for the Times found that 39% of people said they made them unhappy, 38% said happy and 23% couldn't decide. And my favourite survey, one of my favourite surveys ever done, I think was done by the Daily Mirror. And it said to people, would you like to see these European customs in our country? Would you like to see more pavement cafes?
基本上不，也不。所以《泰晤士报》的一项调查发现，39%的人说这让他们不开心，38%的人说开心，23%的人无法决定。我最喜欢的调查之一，我认为是有史以来我最喜欢的调查之一，是由《每日镜报》做的。它问人们，你愿意在我们的国家看到这些欧洲习俗吗？你愿意看到更多的人行道咖啡馆吗？
No, one by 23%. Awful. Would you like to see more shops open on Sundays? No. No, one by 35%. Would you ever like to have coffee in a roll for breakfast? No. No, one by 45.
不，以23%的优势胜出。糟糕。你愿意看到更多商店在周日营业吗？不。不，以35%的优势胜出。你愿意早餐喝咖啡配面包卷吗？不。不，以45%的优势胜出。
I mean, you genuinely wouldn't like to have coffee in a roll for breakfast, Tom. I just think things were better then, you know. Yeah. This is the maddest one, given out the British people's tastes. Would you like to see the pubs open all day as they are in the continent? No, again, one by 26%. They don't really have pubs on the continent, though, do they? That's the problem.
我的意思是，汤姆，你真的不愿意早餐喝咖啡配面包卷吗？我只是觉得那时候事情更好，你知道。是的。考虑到英国人的口味，这是最疯狂的一个。你愿意看到酒吧像在欧洲大陆那样全天营业吗？不，再次以26%的优势胜出。不过，他们在欧洲大陆并没有真正的酒吧，对吧？这就是问题所在。
It's bars. It's all bars, yeah. I think if you had said to people, pay for macfaces are British. Would you like to see more of them? Yes. More hangings. And actually, in 1974, they did another survey,
那是酒吧，是的。我想如果你对人们说，人行道咖啡馆是英国的。你愿意看到更多吗？是的。更多绞刑。事实上，在1974年，他们做了另一项调查，
and they found that two out of three people who regretted joining Europe, they thought it was a terrible idea. And the survey quoted, a trade union official from the black country, which will enable me to do my black country accent, and he said, now that we're in the common market, we're just like all those other countries who are foreigners making decisions for us? Do you think that's actually, I mean, are they experiencing that as something that is directly impacting them? No. Or is it just a kind of vague sense of who are foreigners to tell us what to do? That's exactly what it is. There's nothing,
他们发现三分之二的人后悔加入欧洲，他们认为这是一个糟糕的主意。调查引用了一位来自黑乡的工会官员的话，这让我能模仿我的黑乡口音，他说，现在我们加入了共同市场，我们就像所有那些外国人一样，让外国人为我们做决定？你认为这实际上，我的意思是，他们是否将其体验为直接影响他们的东西？不。还是这只是一种模糊的感觉，即“外国人凭什么告诉我们该怎么做”？这正是它的含义。没有什么，
there's no way in which that trade union official from the black country in which his life has been affected at all by being in the European common market. This brings us back to Harold Wilson and the Labour government. So Wilson, he's not an instinctive European. He always used to say, I've always been a Commonwealth man. And a holiday on the silly house man. When he was in number 10, he said to his age at one point, I don't want French cheese. I don't like French cheese. I mean, who's ever heard of French cheese? I want proper English cheese. Get rid of all this stuff. The problem for him is that the Labour Party is deeply split. So on the one hand, you have the sort of the progressive do-gooding kind of middle classes.
那个来自黑乡的工会官员的生活完全没有受到加入欧洲共同市场的影响。这把我们带回了哈罗德·威尔逊和工党政府。所以威尔逊，他不是一个本能的欧洲人。他总是说，我一直是一个英联邦人。和一个在锡利群岛度假的人。当他在唐宁街10号时，他有一次对他的助手说，我不想要法国奶酪。我不喜欢法国奶酪。我的意思是，谁听说过法国奶酪？我想要正宗的英国奶酪。把所有这些东西都扔掉。对他来说，问题在于工党内部严重分裂。所以一方面，你有那种进步的、爱管闲事的中间阶层。
Roy Jenkins, who will become the head of the European Commission, loves a bottle of claret, loves a French cheese. So he'd been Home Secretary, hadn't he? Yeah. And he's the darling of that wing of the party. He loves Europe. He thinks Europe is the be-all and end-all. And as you say, he goes off to run the European Commission.
罗伊·詹金斯，他将成为欧盟委员会主席，喜欢一瓶红酒，喜欢法国奶酪。所以他曾担任内政大臣，不是吗？是的。他是该党那一翼的宠儿。他热爱欧洲。他认为欧洲是一切。正如你所说，他去管理欧盟委员会了。
And he comes from a Methodist background. Mining family in Wales. And he totally rejects it and kind of transforms himself into a kind of claret swilling grandee. Yeah, he went to Balliol and they put him through a special sort of chemical process that turned him into Rory Stewart. And that's, you know, he came out the other side. Did you get off at that when you went to Bayeliel? I did, but I turned it down. The working class activists and the left of the party hate Europe.
他来自卫理公会背景。威尔士的矿工家庭。他完全拒绝了它，并把自己变成了一种喝红酒的权贵。是的，他去了贝利奥尔学院，他们对他进行了某种特殊的化学处理，把他变成了罗里·斯图尔特。那就是，你知道，他从另一边出来了。你去贝利奥尔学院时，他们对你做过这个吗？我做过，但我拒绝了。工党的工人阶级活动家和左翼讨厌欧洲。
They think it's terrible. It's a threat to socialism. It's a threat to the honest independence of the British working man. So Michael Foote, who was a great sort of tribune of the left of the Labour Party, told his voters in Eber Vale in South Wales, it's a rich nations club opposed to the interests of British democracy and the health of our economy. So Michael Foote is a romantic about British exceptionalism. Yeah. Exactly the way that he not Powell is on the right. And actually they're very good friends, aren't they?
他们认为这很糟糕。这是对社会主义的威胁。这是对英国工人诚实独立的威胁。所以迈克尔·富特，他是工党左翼的一位伟大的论坛人物，告诉他在南威尔士埃布瓦莱的选民，这是一个反对英国民主利益和我们经济健康的富国俱乐部。所以迈克尔·富特是一个关于英国例外论的浪漫主义者。是的。正如右翼的伊诺克·鲍威尔一样。事实上，他们是很好的朋友，不是吗？
They bond over this. And in the second half of this episode, we will discuss how they work together against Europe. Anyway, so Wilson's party is split and he comes up with a great wheeze to avoid pinning his own colours to the mast and to stop the party splitting. He says, I'm in favour of Europe in principle but not in practice. So basically... That's brilliant. He says, he says, Ted Heath has got us in on very bad terms. So when I come back as Prime Minister, I will renegotiate the terms and then I'll hold a referendum so that the people can decide.
他们因此建立了联系。在本集的后半部分，我们将讨论他们如何共同反对欧洲。总之，威尔逊的党分裂了，他想出了一个绝妙的办法来避免表明自己的立场并阻止党的分裂。他说，我原则上支持欧洲，但在实践中不支持。所以基本上……这太棒了。他说，他说，泰德·希思让我们在非常糟糕的条件下加入了。所以当我作为首相回来时，我会重新谈判条款，然后我会举行全民公投，让人民来决定。
Which is exactly Cameron's strategy in 2016. Yeah. Renegotiation and referendum. And it worked for Harold Wilson and Cameron thought it would work for him. Now, there's never been at this point a referendum in Britain. And the reason there's never been a referendum is because we don't need one. We have Parliament. Referendums are foreign. Parliament is sovereign.
这正是卡梅伦在2016年的策略。是的。重新谈判和公投。这对哈罗德·威尔逊有效，卡梅伦认为它对他也会有效。现在，英国此时从未举行过公投。从未举行过公投的原因是我们不需要。我们有议会。公投是外国的。议会是主权的。
Parliament expresses the will of the British people. Which you need to ask people for. They've sent their representatives to Parliament. Also, totalitarian governments use referendums. That was another favourite theme, wasn't it? Yeah, that's what Margaret Thatcher said. It's the divisive dictators. Actually, do you know what?
议会表达了英国人民的意愿。你需要问人民。他们已经把代表送到了议会。此外，极权政府使用公投。那是另一个最喜欢的主题，不是吗？是的，那是玛格丽特·撒切尔说的。这是分裂的独裁者。事实上，你知道吗？
There have been a lot of talk of having referendums before in British history. Nobody ever talks about this. But in the Edwardian period, there had been serious proposals to have referendums about tariff reform, about women's suffrage, about the deadlock between the Lords and the Commons. Churchill wanted to have a referendum in 1945. Winston. Winston, of all people, wanted to have a referendum to keep his own government going at the end of the war with Germany
在英国历史上，关于举行公投的讨论很多。从来没有人谈论这个。但在爱德华时代，曾有过关于关税改革、妇女选举权、上议院和下议院之间僵局的严肃公投提议。丘吉尔想在1945年举行公投。温斯顿。温斯顿，所有人中，想在与德国的战争结束时举行公投以维持他自己的政府
to keep it going during the war with Japan and Clement Attlee said no, didn't agree with it. But Harold Wilson is now back as Prime Minister and the referendum is on. So he goes to the Europeans, he says, I want to renegotiate Britain's terms. Do they understand what he's doing? Do they get the politics of it?
在与日本的战争期间维持它，而克莱门特·艾德礼说不，不同意。但哈罗德·威尔逊现在又回到了首相职位，公投正在进行。所以他去找欧洲人，他说，我想重新谈判英国的条款。他们明白他在做什么吗？他们明白其中的政治吗？
I mean, they're pretty annoyed about it. They do get the politics of it and they want Britain to stay in, so they agree to do it. But they're not best pleased. There's an excellent cartoon in the French equivalent of private eye. the satirical magazine Le Canard en chene.
我的意思是，他们对此非常恼火。他们确实明白其中的政治，他们希望英国留下来，所以他们同意这样做。但他们并不高兴。在法国版的《私家侦探》中有一幅出色的漫画。讽刺杂志《鸭鸣报》。
And it shows this sort of a very French cartoon. It shows this Wilson as this sort of ludicrous little figure lying between the legs of a naked woman.
它展示了这种非常法国的漫画。它展示了威尔逊，这个荒谬的小人物，躺在一个裸体女人的双腿之间。
And the woman was so French. The woman wears a crown labelled Europe and the woman says to him in French, get in or get out, my dear Wilson,
那个女人太法国了。女人戴着一顶标有“欧洲”的皇冠，女人用法语对他说，进来或者出去，我亲爱的威尔逊，
but do stop all this ridiculous coming and going. Anyway, they have the renegotiation. Wilson sent his Foreign Secretary James Callaghan who later complained that he spent most of his time
但别再搞这些荒谬的来来去去了。总之，他们进行了重新谈判。威尔逊派了他的外交大臣詹姆斯·卡拉汉，他后来抱怨说他大部分时间都花在
arguing about, and I quote, the fixed position of rearview mirrors on agricultural tractors. That's the British image of the European project. Nothing about stopping the rise of fascism. No. So March 75th, 17th of March, Wilson goes to see his cabinet and he says, I've got a great deal for Britain, a great new deal. Now, actually, it's basically exactly the same as Ted Heath's deal with a couple of superficial differences. And he also says, thanks to mine renegotiation.
争论，我引用，“农业拖拉机后视镜的固定位置”。这就是英国对欧洲项目的形象。没有什么关于阻止法西斯主义崛起的内容。不。所以3月75日，3月17日，威尔逊去见他的内阁，他说，我为英国达成了一笔伟大的交易，一笔伟大的新交易。现在，实际上，它基本上与泰德·希思的交易完全一样，只有几个肤浅的区别。他还说，多亏了我的重新谈判，
we have stopped Europe from developing in a federalist direction. And as long as we stay in, we will stop it. I mean, how many times were we to hear that in the next 20 years or whatever? Now, his lefty ministers did not agree. So one of them, Tony Benn, who we talk about after the break, said, this is rubbish. The community will destroy the whole basis in which the Labour movement was founded and our commitment to democratic change.
我们阻止了欧洲向联邦主义方向发展。只要我们留下来，我们就会阻止它。我的意思是，在接下来的20年左右的时间里，我们听过多少次这样的话？现在，他的左翼部长们不同意。所以其中之一，托尼·本，我们在休息后会谈到他，说，这是垃圾。共同体将摧毁工党运动建立的基础以及我们对民主变革的承诺。
But Wilson is adamant. The deal is done. the first referendum in British history is set for Thursday the 5th of June. Wilson himself will advise the British people to vote yes, but his ministers can campaign on whatever side they like. And the question is very simple. Do you think the United Kingdom should stay in the European community? God, unbelievable tension.
但威尔逊很坚定。交易完成了。英国历史上第一次公投定于6月5日星期四。威尔逊本人将建议英国人民投赞成票，但他的部长们可以为他们喜欢的任何一方竞选。问题非常简单。你认为联合王国应该留在欧洲共同体吗？天哪，令人难以置信的紧张。
So how will the British people vote in this referendum? And most crucially of all, can Paul McCartney swing the balance? We'll find out after the break. Hey, this is Michael and Hannah from Gollhangers The Rest is Science. This episode is brought to you by Cancer Research UK. We often think of beating cancer as treatment, but imagine stopping it before it begins. After years of work, Cancer Research UK scientists are launching a clinical trial of lung vax, the first vaccine designed to prevent lung cancer.
那么英国人民将如何在这次公投中投票？最关键的是，保罗·麦卡特尼能扭转局面吗？休息后我们会知道。嘿，这是来自Gollhangers《科学的其余部分》的迈克尔和汉娜。本集由英国癌症研究中心为您呈现。我们经常认为战胜癌症就是治疗，但想象一下在它开始之前就阻止它。经过多年的工作，英国癌症研究中心科学家正在启动肺疫苗的临床试验，这是第一个旨在预防肺癌的疫苗。
It builds on TracerX, the world's largest cancer evolution study, which tracked lung cancer cells over many years to uncover the disease's earliest warning signs. Lung Vax is designed to train the immune system to spot these signs early on, destroying 40 cells before cancer develops. So it's not treatment, but preventative, with the potential to stop lung cancer before it starts. The first stage of the trial starts this year, focusing on people at higher risk. It shows what long-term research makes possible. For more information about about Cancer Research UK, their research breakthroughs and how you can support them, visit Cancer Researchuk.org forward slash the rest is science.
它建立在TracerX的基础上，这是世界上最大的癌症进化研究，它追踪肺癌细胞多年，以揭示该疾病最早的预警信号。肺疫苗旨在训练免疫系统在早期发现这些迹象，在癌症发展之前摧毁40个细胞。所以这不是治疗，而是预防，有可能在肺癌开始之前就阻止它。试验的第一阶段今年开始，重点关注高风险人群。它展示了长期研究使什么成为可能。有关英国癌症研究中心、他们的研究突破以及你如何支持他们的更多信息，请访问Cancer Researchuk.org斜杠the rest is science。
One day you're negotiating with suppliers. The next, you're installing a shelf in the back room. Running a business means moving in many directions all the time. TD's new small business banking accounts are built for how your business moves. It's how we're making banking more human. Hello everyone and welcome back to The Restless History, where it is the late spring of 1975 and the date has been set for Britain's first referendum. And the choice is simple. It's between splendid isolation and continental brotherhood. And you couldn't think of anything really more likely to galvanise people and get them talking with huge excitement about politics in the pubs that they don't want to open all day.
一天你在与供应商谈判。第二天，你在后室安装架子。经营企业意味着一直向多个方向移动。道明银行新的小企业银行账户是为你的业务如何移动而建立的。这就是我们如何让银行业务更人性化。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》，现在是1975年的晚春，英国第一次公投的日期已经确定。选择很简单。这是在辉煌的孤立和大陆兄弟情谊之间。你无法想到任何更有可能激励人们并让他们在他们不想全天营业的酒吧里兴奋地谈论政治的事情，
and in the non-existent pavement cafes in the street cafes that they regard as foreign rubbish. Yeah, well actually, do you know what? No one cares. I mean, that's the thing with this. So it's odd to be doing a subject on the rest of the history
以及在街头咖啡馆里，他们认为那是外国垃圾。是的，好吧，实际上，你知道吗？没人关心。我的意思是，这就是这件事的情况。所以做一个关于历史其余部分的主题很奇怪
that nobody cared about. But it's Europe. It's not surprising. So basically, the referendum is on and for weeks nothing happens at all. There have been two elections in the last year and people are sick about another election. It's the last thing they want.
没人关心。但这是欧洲。这并不奇怪。所以基本上，公投正在进行，几周来什么也没发生。去年有两次选举，人们对另一次选举感到厌倦。这是他们最不想要的。
So it only really gets going with a couple of weeks to go and the two sides start holding press conferences. And we'll start, you know, since we're a sister podcast of the rest of politics, we'll start where they would want us to start with the Remainers of the day, with the Yes campaign. So the best known Remainer is Harold Wilson. I mean, he's so unenthusiastic. You know, he's very like Jeremy Corbyn in 2016.
所以它只有在离结束还有几周时才真正开始，双方开始举行新闻发布会。我们将开始，你知道，既然我们是政治其余部分的姐妹播客，我们将从他们希望我们开始的地方开始，与当天的留欧派，与赞成运动。所以最著名的留欧派是哈罗德·威尔逊。我的意思是，他太不热情了。你知道，他非常像2016年的杰里米·科尔宾。
His aide Bernard Donoghue wrote in his diary, Harold is clearly unhappy about having to come out so firmly in favour of the market. He's really a little Englander, and at heart he agrees with every word that no campaign says. So he fights to the end against actually telling people to vote yes, which is true. He did. He did it very half-heartedly. Now, part of the reason for that is his own party is so split. So they're split right down the middle. Seven of his cabinet ministers are levers and about half of his MPs.
他的助手伯纳德·多诺霍在他的日记中写道，哈罗德显然对不得不如此坚定地支持市场感到不快。他真的是一个小英格兰人，内心深处他同意反对运动所说的每一个字。所以他战斗到最后，反对真正告诉人们投赞成票，这是真的。他确实这样做了。他做得非常敷衍。现在，部分原因是由于他自己的党如此分裂。所以他们从中间分裂了。他的七名内阁部长是脱欧派，大约一半的议员也是。
And the unions too are divided about 50-50. Oh, really? I thought the unions were really against it. No, there are a couple of unions. A lot of the big unions are against it, but there are other unions. are for it. So it's not quite as simple as it's sometimes painted. Now, by contrast, the Tories are much more pro-remain. And the Tories by this point are led by noted Euro enthusiast Margaret Thatcher. And she's all over it, isn't she? So Margaret Thatcher, this is a funny thing. Thatcher's relationship with Europe is always really ambiguous. So her father, Alfred Roberts,
工会也分裂了大约50-50。哦，真的吗？我以为工会真的反对它。不，有几个工会。许多大工会反对它，但还有其他工会。是支持它的。所以它并不像有时描绘的那样简单。相比之下，保守党更支持留欧。而保守党此时由著名的欧洲爱好者玛格丽特·撒切尔领导。她对此非常投入，不是吗？所以玛格丽特·撒切尔，这是一件有趣的事。撒切尔与欧洲的关系总是非常模糊。所以她的父亲，阿尔弗雷德·罗伯茨，
we talked about him in the last episode. He once told the Grantham Rotary Club, I would sooner be a boot black in England than a leading citizen and a good many of the other leading countries in the world today, the person who polishes your boots. And that I think is very much her vibe. She thinks being British is to have won first place
我们在上一集谈到了他。他曾经告诉格兰瑟姆扶轮社，我宁愿在英国做一个擦鞋匠，也不愿做当今世界上其他许多领先国家的领先公民，那个擦亮你靴子的人。我认为这非常符合她的氛围。她认为身为英国人就是赢得了第一名
in the lottery of life. Europeans cannot be trusted. They're sneaky, they don't follow the rules, all of this stuff. They wear ludicrous uniforms. They're always invading Poland. All of that. Right, exactly.
在人生的彩票中。欧洲人不可信。他们狡猾，他们不遵守规则，所有这些东西。他们穿着荒谬的制服。他们总是入侵波兰。所有这些。对，没错。
However, she's also a free trader and she likes open markets, and a lot of Tories, including Margaret Thatcher, see Europe as a bulwook against socialism. So it's a kind of, it's part of the Cold War, basically. The Western Alliance, Tom, free nations. Exactly. So in 1975, she is all for it.
然而，她也是一个自由贸易者，她喜欢开放市场，许多保守党人，包括玛格丽特·撒切尔，将欧洲视为对抗社会主义的堡垒。所以这是一种，它是冷战的一部分，基本上。西方联盟，汤姆，自由国家。没错。所以1975年，她全力支持它。
She tells a press conference, there is no genuine alternative to working closely together. And she boasts, you know, we did this. We got Britain to Europe. The Conservative Party has been pursuing the European vision almost as long as we existed as a party. We are inextricably part of Europe.
她在新闻发布会上说，没有真正的替代方案可以紧密合作。她吹嘘说，你知道，我们做到了。我们让英国进入了欧洲。保守党追求欧洲愿景的时间几乎和我们作为一个党存在的时间一样长。我们不可分割地是欧洲的一部分。
Europe is where we are and where we have always been. Now, at this first press conference, there's an excellent moment. It takes us back to something we discussed last time. Because she's sitting next to the chairman of the Conservative Group for Europe, the great totem of Britain in Europe, Ted Heath, who hates her with a passion. And she says to Ted Heath, you can see the clip online, it's really funny. She says she plays the sort of bashful protégé.
欧洲是我们所在的地方，也是我们一直所在的地方。现在，在第一次新闻发布会上，有一个精彩的时刻。它把我们带回了我们上次讨论的内容。因为她坐在保守党欧洲小组主席旁边，英国在欧洲的伟大图腾，泰德·希思，他非常恨她。她对泰德·希思说，你可以在网上看到这段视频，非常有趣。她说她扮演那种害羞的门徒。
she says to Ted Heath, she turns to him and she says, you have done more than anyone else for the conservative cause in Europe and to see that Britain's places in Europe naturally it is with some temerity that the pupil speaks before the master because you know more about it
她对泰德·希思说，她转向他说，你为欧洲的保守党事业做了比任何人都多的贡献，看到英国在欧洲的地位，自然地，学生在老师面前说话是有些胆怯的，因为你比我们任何人都更了解它
than any of the rest of us and the camera at this point the camera sort of moves across Ted Heath and he is staring at her with unalloyed hatred that says nothing. Is she at this point wearing her comedy Euro jumper.
比我们其余的人，摄像机此时摄像机移动到泰德·希思身上，他正以纯粹的仇恨盯着她，什么也没说。她此时穿着她的喜剧欧洲毛衣吗？
No. Which with all the European flags on it. I love this. So she doesn't wear it at the press conference but she wears it later at a photo call
不。上面有所有欧洲旗帜的那件。我喜欢这个。所以她在新闻发布会上没穿它，但她后来在拍照时穿了它
by Churchill's statue. She wears this tremendous jumper. So there's nine women in jumpers or t-shirts with European flags on. And then there's Margaret Thatcher in a jumper
在丘吉尔的雕像旁。她穿着这件巨大的毛衣。所以有九个女人穿着带有欧洲旗帜的毛衣或T恤。然后是玛格丽特·撒切尔穿着一件毛衣
with all the flags of the European countries. And it's just such a laughable image. And presumably whenever a sort of Tory Euro-sceptic
带有所有欧洲国家的旗帜。这真是一个可笑的形象。大概每当某种保守党欧洲怀疑论者
today, You know, when Jacob Rees-Mogg contemplates that image, he must be, I mean, steam must come out of his ears. Like the circuits must explode or something. And in fact, the whole yes campaign, really, the backbone of it was the Tory party. So they provided a lot of the organisational muscle. The headquarters of the Yes campaign was donated by Mrs Thatcher's party treasurer, Alistair MacAlpine. It's a big business campaign, so they get tons of money from Shell, Ford, IBM, ICI, all the biggest firms in the country.
今天，你知道，当雅各布·里斯-莫格思考那个形象时，他一定，我的意思是，蒸汽一定从他的耳朵里冒出来。就像电路一定爆炸了一样。事实上，整个赞成运动，真的，它的骨干是保守党。所以他们提供了很多组织力量。赞成运动的总部是由撒切尔夫人的党财务主管阿拉斯泰尔·麦卡尔平捐赠的。这是一个大企业运动，所以他们从壳牌、福特、IBM、ICI等全国最大的公司获得了大量资金。
They have a war chest of one and a half million pounds, which is the biggest war chest that any side had ever had in a British electoral campaign. And it's ten times as much as the no campaign had. So, I mean, they're able to absolutely obliterate the leave campaign. So left-wing kind of suspicion of the common market as a capitalist plot. I mean, there's a kind of element of, I mean, it's kind of illustrating that. Well, I mean, I suppose at some level it is a capitalist plot. I mean, Christian Democrats do play a big part in setting up the European Union. No, but I mean that it is the forces of capitalism in Britain who are funding this against, you could frame it as the, you know, the oppressed working masses who can't tap all this money.
他们有一个150万英镑的战争基金，这是英国选举运动中任何一方有史以来最大的战争基金。它是反对运动拥有的十倍。所以，我的意思是，他们能够彻底消灭脱欧运动。所以左翼对共同市场作为资本主义阴谋的怀疑。我的意思是，有一种，我的意思是，它在某种程度上说明了这一点。嗯，我的意思是，我想在某种程度上它是一个资本主义阴谋。我的意思是，基督教民主党人在建立欧盟方面发挥了很大作用。不，但我的意思是，正是英国的资本主义力量在资助这个，反对，你可以将其解读为，你知道，被压迫的工人群众，他们无法利用所有这些钱。
I think you could frame it and there'd be an element of truth in it. I mean, I don't necessarily think that's a bad thing. But I think you're dead right. Big business wants us to join the European project and wants us to stay in. because they want the markets and they want the integration, much more so than in 2016 when it was more divided. But business is unanimous in the 1970s. They've also got celebrities, so Graham Green came out in favour of it. Alex Guinness, Toby Juan Kenobi,
我认为你可以这样解读，并且其中会有真实成分。我的意思是，我不一定认为这是一件坏事。但我认为你说得完全正确。大企业希望我们加入欧洲项目并希望我们留下来。因为他们想要市场，他们想要一体化，比2016年更甚，当时它更分裂。但企业在70年代是一致的。他们也有名人，所以格雷厄姆·格林支持它。亚历克·吉尼斯，欧比旺·克诺比，
Peter Eustinoff, Hercule Poirot, and the England football manager, Don Revi, soon to be disgraced. He came out in favour it as well. And there's generally a very rest is politics he vile. to the campaign. So it's basically sensible, moderate people meeting up.
彼得·乌斯蒂诺夫，赫尔克里·波洛，以及英格兰足球经理唐·里维，很快就会蒙羞。他也支持它。而且通常有一种非常“政治其余部分”的氛围。对竞选。所以基本上是理智、温和的人聚在一起。
Yes. Coming together. We agree on common sense policies for Britain. Exactly. So that's at the top and then at the grassroots you basically have a much more
是的。聚在一起。我们同意为英国制定常识性政策。没错。所以那是在高层，然后在基层，你基本上有一个更
it's quite herbivorous. It's quite Lib Dem. So there's gin and tonic parties. There's basically people get together and compare their lovely beards. There's actually some places where they genuinely hold meetings of vegetarian
它相当草食。它相当自由民主党。所以有金酒和汤力派对。基本上人们聚在一起比较他们可爱的胡子。实际上有些地方他们真的举行素食会议
in restaurants. It's very mid-70s, herbivorous behaviour. Let's get to the No campaign. The No campaign has a very different vibe. These are the people who want to leave and these are some very peculiar combinations. So basically, I'll give you two examples. One is Ipswich. In Ipswich, the No campaign was run by an alliance of Labour, the Communists, people on the very right of the Tories and a married couple who were described as, quote, not quite National Front but close. So quite like X. Twitter as was. That's that kind of vibe.
在餐馆里。这是非常70年代中期的草食行为。让我们谈谈反对运动。反对运动有非常不同的氛围。这些人是想要离开的人，这些是一些非常奇特的组合。所以基本上，我给你两个例子。一个是伊普斯威奇。在伊普斯威奇，反对运动由工党、共产党、保守党极右翼人士和一对被描述为，引用，“不完全是国民阵线但很接近”的已婚夫妇联盟领导。所以很像X。推特曾经的样子。那是那种氛围。
Yeah. So Burnley, where Tony Pastor at Goalhanger boss comes from, the No campaign was run by an anarchist, a communist, some Labour Party activists, and a very lone and friendless Tory. And they didn't get on very well. And as one of them said afterwards, our campaign was a shambles from beginning to end. That's Burnley for you.
是的。所以伯恩利，Goalhanger老板托尼·帕斯托来自那里，反对运动由一名无政府主义者、一名共产主义者、一些工党活动家和一名非常孤独且没有朋友的保守党人领导。他们相处得不太好。正如其中一人后来所说，我们的竞选从头到尾都是一场混乱。这就是伯恩利。
The one thing the no campaign have is the support of one of your favourite people, Tom. So Paul McCartney. I think probably my favourite person. He's virtually the only celebrity who votes, who says he wants to leave in 1975. And his rationale, he says Europe is very much like the Beatles. Now the partnership has been dissolved. I'm much better off. He didn't really mean it, though.
反对运动唯一拥有的东西是你的最爱之一的支持，汤姆。所以保罗·麦卡特尼。我想大概是我最喜欢的人。他是1975年几乎唯一一个投票，说他想离开的名人。他的理由，他说欧洲非常像披头士乐队。现在合伙关系已经解散了。我好多了。不过他并不是真的那样想。
Do you not think he meant it? No, he didn't mean it. About the Beatles or about Europe? Both, I think, because he didn't vote in the Brexit referendum. In 2016? Yeah. And then he ended up saying, actually, I think Brexit's a bad idea. Ringo was all in favour of Brexit.
你不认为他是认真的吗？不，他不是认真的。关于披头士还是关于欧洲？我想两者都是，因为他在脱欧公投中没有投票。在2016年？是的。然后他最终说，实际上，我认为脱欧是个坏主意。林戈完全支持脱欧。
it. Paul, I feel like if you shouted your mouth off in 75, you should at least turn up in 2016. No? It couldn't make his mind up. Okay, fair enough. The big problem the no campaign have is they have absolutely no money. The yes campaign, I described them as having one and a half million pounds. The no campaign have 133,000 pounds. And unbelievably, all but nine thousand pounds of this came from the government. So basically, they only raise nine thousand pounds. And as one account of the campaign puts it, it was a race between a Formula One car and a bicycle. And the other big problem they have is the people who are their spokesmen are very, very unpopular. Yes. So who've they got? Dominic.
它。保罗，我觉得如果你在75年大放厥词，你至少应该在2016年出现。不是吗？无法下定决心。好吧，公平地说。反对运动面临的最大问题是他们根本没有钱。赞成运动，我描述他们有150万英镑。反对运动有133,000英镑。令人难以置信的是，除了9000英镑外，所有这些都来自政府。所以基本上，他们只筹集了9000英镑。正如对竞选的一次描述所说，这是一场一级方程式赛车和自行车之间的比赛。他们面临的另一个大问题是他们的发言人非常、非常不受欢迎。是的。所以他们有谁？多米尼克。
They've got Enoch Powell, who some people may remember from last time, they have the radical pamphleteer Michael Foote. So we'll be having a bit more of him on the show in the next week. Very long hair. Yeah, long white hair. Thick, thick glasses loves Jonathan Swift and Byron. Byron and the romantics and Haslett and all this stuff. but he looks about 6,000 years old, doesn't he? He looks like Wurzell Gummage, the scarecrow.
他们有以诺·鲍威尔，有些人可能还记得上次提到他，他们还有激进的小册子作者迈克尔·富特。所以下周节目里我们会更多地谈到他。他头发很长。是的，长长的白发。戴着厚厚的眼镜，热爱乔纳森·斯威夫特和拜伦。拜伦、浪漫主义者、哈兹利特以及所有这些东西。但他看起来有6000岁了，不是吗？他看起来像稻草人沃泽尔·冈米奇。
Right. And then Tony Ben, and we'll come to Tony Ben in just a second. He's the main spokesman, really. And a cartoon in the evening standard had a Get Britain Out March. It showed a great lever's march, led by all these three people, and they were surrounded by banners reading Trotskis, National Front, Orange Order, Communist Party, IRA. And that sort of summed up the public perception.
对。然后是托尼·本，我们马上就会谈到托尼·本。他其实是主要发言人。《伦敦标准晚报》上有一幅漫画，画的是“让英国退出”游行。画中展示了一场声势浩大的游行，由这三个人领头，周围环绕着写有“托洛茨基分子”、“国民阵线”、“奥兰治兄弟会”、“共产党”、“爱尔兰共和军”字样的横幅。这总结了公众的看法。
that they were fruit cakes and lunatics or whatever Cameron said about Brexit. Exactly. And this brings us to their chief spokesman who is Tony Ben. Now, Tony Ben in the 1970s, I mean, he's also been in Love Island, hasn't he? Didn't he come on Love Island? He has appeared on the rest of history a few times.
他们是疯子、怪人，或者卡梅伦对脱欧所说的任何评价。没错。这就引出了他们的首席发言人托尼·本。托尼·本在70年代，我的意思是，他也上过《恋爱岛》，不是吗？他没上过《恋爱岛》吗？他确实在《历史的其余部分》节目中出现过几次。
And he won. Yeah, he did. The salient thing for people to remember about Tony Ben is that he gets stung on the penis by a wasp. When I was doing the notes, I didn't bother writing it down because I knew you would mention it. Because that's the single most important thing about him. And he puts it in his diaries.
而且他赢了。是的，他赢了。关于托尼·本，人们需要记住的最突出的事情是，他的阴茎被黄蜂蜇了。我做笔记的时候，没费心写下来，因为我知道你会提。因为这是关于他最重要的一件事。而且他把这写进了日记里。
Or stung on the penis by a washp, as he would actually have put it. For our non-British listeners, it's going to be hard to express how well known and how controversial. How controversial his political persona was in the 70s and 80s. In all the history of the Labour Party, I think he stands as the politician dearest to the heart. of kind of left-wing party activists. And in his pomp in the 1970s, people had no doubt whatsoever that he was the future of British politics.
或者像他本人所说的那样，被黄蜂蜇了阴茎。对于我们非英国听众来说，很难表达他在70和80年代的政治形象是多么出名和具有争议性。在工党的整个历史上，我认为他是最受左翼党内活动人士爱戴的政治家。在70年代他的鼎盛时期，人们毫无疑问地认为他是英国政治的未来。
He was an absolutely defining political figure. He's 50 years old, so same age as Margaret Thatcher. He comes from a long line of progressive politicians. His father, Viscount Stansgate, defected from the Liberals to Labour in the 1920s. And he has to kind of turn down his own peerage, doesn't he? Yeah, renounce his own peerage.
他是一个绝对具有决定性的政治人物。他当时50岁，和玛格丽特·撒切尔同龄。他出身于一个进步政治家世家。他的父亲斯坦斯盖特子爵在20世纪20年代从自由党倒戈加入工党。他不得不放弃自己的爵位，不是吗？是的，放弃了自己的爵位。
to carry on as an MP vendors. And he started out working for Howard Wilson as a technocratic minister of technology, among other things. But after they were turfed out in 1970, he had this, I think, genuinely, I mean, evangelical is the word, he has this kind of evangelical conversion. He's from a long line of, you know, Methodists and whatnot. And it's as though he has been born again. That's the only way to describe the intensity of it.
以便继续担任议员。他最初是为哈罗德·威尔逊工作，担任技术部长等职务。但在1970年他们被赶下台后，他经历了一次，我认为是真诚的，我的意思是，用“福音派”这个词很贴切，他经历了一种福音派式的转变。他出身于卫理公会教徒等家庭。就好像他重生了一样。这是描述其强烈程度的唯一方式。
he becomes an enthusiast for absolutely every conceivable left-wing cause, particularly things like workers' control, an industrial democracy. He wants to have, for example, to set up a rival, what he calls a working-class power structure run by the trade unions that would govern the country alongside Parliament. He wants to ditch nuclear weapons and pull out of NATO. He's fervently anti-European. He sees Europe as a capitalist cartel, and it will make it impossible. to build socialism in one country.
他成为了每一个可以想象到的左翼事业的热情支持者，特别是工人控制和工业民主等事业。例如，他想要建立一个他所谓的由工会运作的工人阶级权力结构，与议会并列治理国家。他想要放弃核武器并退出北约。他狂热地反欧洲。他认为欧洲是一个资本主义卡特尔，这会使在一个国家内建立社会主义变得不可能。
And the funny thing about writing about Tony Benn, I love writing about and I've written about him a lot in my books, is the paradox that his colleagues universally said, he's an extremely nice man. He's very courteous, he's kind, he's polite, he's charming. And then they would say in the next breath, I hate him. Because they would say he is disloyal, he is narcissistic, He's unctuous, he's hypocritical, his self-serving, you cannot trust him, all of this kind of stuff.
关于写托尼·本，有趣的是，我喜欢写他，而且在我的书中写过他很多次，这就是一个悖论：他的同事们普遍说，他是一个非常好的人。他非常有礼貌，善良，客气，迷人。然后他们紧接着会说，我恨他。因为他们会说他背信弃义、自恋、虚伪、伪善、自私自利，你不能信任他，诸如此类。
And those two things which seems so contradictory, you know, people, lots of people that he worked with held both those ideas in their heads at once. By the time Labour got back in 1974, he'd become a complete bogeyman to the British press. The cartoonists commonly drew him either wearing a Nazi uniform or a communist uniform because they regarded him as a kind of totalitarian. waiting. Wilson doesn't really trust him, but because Wilson has no majority and he cannot afford to alienate the left, he has made Ben his industry secretary. And since coming back to power, Ben has been working on this extraordinary program of socialist transformation. He wants to force all major companies in Britain to sign planning agreements with the state, and he wants to set up a national enterprise board to take over companies in the public interest. In fact,
这两件看起来如此矛盾的事情，你知道，许多与他共事的人脑子里同时持有这两种想法。到1974年工党重新掌权时，他已经成了英国媒体眼中彻头彻尾的恶魔。漫画家通常把他画成穿着纳粹制服或共产主义制服，因为他们认为他是一个潜在的极权主义者。威尔逊并不真正信任他，但因为威尔逊没有多数席位，他不能疏远左翼，所以他让本担任了工业大臣。自重掌大权以来，本一直在制定这个非凡的社会主义改造计划。他想强迫英国所有大公司与国家签署规划协议，并想建立一个国家企业委员会，以公共利益为名接管公司。事实上，
Ben wanted to use the Emergency Powers Act to take over the 25 biggest companies in Britain straight away and build a new economy on the principle of workers' control. This provoked great horror in the city and eventually Jim Callaghan and Dennis Healy went to see Harold Wilson and said, You've got to rein this bloke in, he's out of control. His plans were emasculated and he had to console himself
本想利用《紧急权力法》立即接管英国最大的25家公司，并在工人控制的原则上建立一个新的经济体系。这在伦敦金融城引起了极大的恐慌，最终吉姆·卡拉汉和丹尼斯·希利去见哈罗德·威尔逊说，你必须约束这个家伙，他失控了。他的计划被阉割了，他不得不自我安慰，
by investing public money in three workers' cooperatives. So one of them was a newspaper in Scotland called the Scottish Daily News that went bust after six. six months. One of them was a motorbike cooperative in Birmingham that managed to struggle on for eight years. But my favourite by far is this former washing machine factory in Merseyside, which had been occupied by its own workers when it went bust. Ben wanted to give them four million pounds of public money. And his own consultants working for the Department of Industry told him this was absolutely insane. Don't do it. And when he brought it up in Cabinet,
通过向三个工人合作社投入公共资金。其中一个是苏格兰的一家报纸，叫《苏格兰日报》，六个月后就倒闭了。其中一个是伯明翰的摩托车合作社，勉强维持了八年。但我最喜欢的是默西塞德郡的一家前洗衣机工厂，它在倒闭时被自己的工人占领了。本想给他们四百万英镑的公共资金。他自己在工业部工作的顾问告诉他这绝对是疯了。别这么做。当他在内阁提出这件事时，
I mean, he describes it in his diary. Some of the other ministers literally laugh in his face when he tells them his plan. I mean, that's what's wonderful about his diaries, isn't it? It's the kind of, there's a pooterish quality. Dennis laughed in my face again. Completely. Kind of innocence, almost. It's a diary.
我的意思是，他在日记里描述了这件事。当他告诉他们他的计划时，其他一些部长简直是在当面嘲笑他。我的意思是，这就是他的日记精彩的地方，不是吗？有一种普特式的特质。丹尼斯又当面嘲笑我了。完全是。几乎是一种天真。这是一本日记。
It's that rare thing of a diary written by a really unreliable narrator. You know, a narrator who's telling you, but one side of the story, but you can completely see the reality of what's happening, which is he's gone to the cabinet, he said, I've got an extra plan for rest of all this money, and they say to him, well, what would the factory make? He says it would make car radiators and orange juice. A great pairing.
这是一本由一个非常不可靠的叙述者所写的罕见日记。你知道，一个只告诉你故事一面的叙述者，但你完全能看出正在发生的事实，那就是他去了内阁，说，我有一个关于所有这些钱的额外计划，他们问他，工厂会生产什么？他说会生产汽车散热器和橙汁。绝妙的搭配。
To quote myself in Seasons and the Sun, history offers few examples of successful factories making both car parts and orange juice. Imagine this one in Cuba. There must be some reason. Maybe there's some crossover in the equipment. If we have any listeners who are industrialists, let us know. The bonkers thing about this, Wilson said, oh, give them the money.
引用我在《四季与太阳》中的话，历史上很少有成功的工厂既生产汽车零部件又生产橙汁的例子。想象一下古巴的这家工厂。一定有什么原因。也许设备上有某种交叉。如果我们有任何工业家听众，请告诉我们。这件事最疯狂的地方在于，威尔逊说，哦，给他们钱。
And they did give them the money. Yeah, anything for a quiet life. How did it work? They went bust in 1978. It was not a success. I mean, I would not buy my orange juice from a factory that I knew. A publicly funded factory that was also making car radiators. I would raise an eyebrow to say that it's...
他们确实给了他们钱。是的，为了过安稳日子什么都行。结果如何？他们在1978年倒闭了。这并不成功。我的意思是，我不会从一家我知道的工厂买橙汁。一家由公共资助的工厂，同时还在生产汽车散热器。我会挑起眉毛说，这……
Anyway, all this means that by the time of the referendum, Ben is an incredibly controversial figure. He's probably the most abused minister in modern political history. He's making the headlines day after day, and I'll just give you two examples. To give you a sense, one of them is so 70s. The Sunday Times ran a huge cartoon of him. Listeners to steal themselves, showing him as a rapist, dragging off a screaming woman who represents British industry.
总之，所有这些意味着在公投时，本是一个极具争议的人物。他可能是现代政治史上被辱骂最多的部长。他每天都上头条，我只给你举两个例子。让你感受一下，其中一个太70年代了。《星期日泰晤士报》刊登了一幅关于他的巨幅漫画。听众们要做好心理准备，画中他是一个强奸犯，拖走了一个代表英国工业的尖叫妇女。
And Ben is saying, good heavens, everyone knows that when a woman says no, she really means yes. That is very 70s. That's number one. And number two, an editorial in the Times, I mean, one of the most, surely one of the most damning editorials ever published in the Times about a single politician. Ben is a dangerous politician who stirs up and exploits political forces that will first bring Britain to economic ruin
本说，天哪，每个人都知道当一个女人说不时，她其实是指是的。这非常70年代。这是第一个。第二个是《泰晤士报》的一篇社论，我的意思是，这肯定是《泰晤士报》有史以来针对单一政治家发表的最严厉的社论之一。本是一个危险的政治家，他煽动并利用政治力量，这些力量将首先把英国带向经济崩溃，
and then use the rubble as the foundations for a collectivist regime. And basically, they're saying he's Alexander Kerensky or somebody. Yeah. He gets death threats in the campaign, but that he's undeterred. He tours the land, giving endless speeches about the threat of Europe. the more he speaks, the more support for his cause falls. You know, he basically puts people off, but that never stops him because he's an evangelist. He's preaching of the gospel.
然后利用废墟作为集体主义政权的基石。基本上，他们是在说他是亚历山大·克伦斯基之类的人。是的。他在竞选期间收到过死亡威胁，但他毫不退缩。他巡回全国，发表了无数关于欧洲威胁的演讲。他讲得越多，对他事业的支持就越少。你知道，他基本上让人们反感，但这从未阻止他，因为他是一个福音传道者。他在宣扬福音。
I mean, he does have this, his famous five questions, isn't it? You know, what power have you got and where did you get it from and how can I get rid of you? And I can't remember what the other ones are. But, I mean, there is something quite powerful about that. He's a good, brilliant speaker. I mean, he's a brilliant speaker. And he says that if you can't remove somebody who has control over your life, then you don't live in a democracy. It's not a bad point.
我的意思是，他确实有他著名的五个问题，不是吗？你知道，你有什么权力，你从哪里得到的，我怎么才能摆脱你？我不记得其他的是什么了。但是，我的意思是，这确实有一些非常强大的地方。他是一个优秀的、出色的演说家。我的意思是，他是一位出色的演说家。他说，如果你不能罢免一个控制你生活的人，那么你就不是生活在民主国家。这不是一个坏观点。
And that is probably the single most powerful argument that could be made against the common market. I urge listeners, you can go onto YouTube, you can find loads and loads of his speeches, or indeed Michael Futs or Enoch Powers or whatever about Europe. I mean, the three of them, one thing they have in common, whatever you think of their politics, they're brilliant speakers. And Tony Benn, I've written about him a lot, I find him a very engaging person. person to write about. I do think he's deluded, but I think he's clever, he's a wonderfully fluent, amusing, sort of dazzlingly good speaker, actually. So you will have watched all the
这可能是反对共同市场最强有力的论点。我敦促听众，你们可以去YouTube，可以找到大量他的演讲，或者迈克尔·富特或以诺·鲍威尔关于欧洲的演讲。我的意思是，他们三个人，无论你如何看待他们的政治观点，他们都是出色的演说家。托尼·本，我写过很多关于他的文章，我觉得他是一个非常吸引人的写作对象。我确实认为他被误导了，但我认为他很聪明，他是一个非常流利、有趣、令人眼花缭乱的好演说家。所以你一定看了所有的
debates, I guess, that went on for this referendum, and you will have watched lots that went on in 2016. Yeah. How does the standard of the debate compare? There is no comparison whatsoever. the standard in 1975, to say that it's above that of 2016, is to massively undersell it. I mean, the level, if you, there's a, there's a, this brilliant debate, for example, between Roy Jenkins and Tony Benn that you can see online. I think it is, and there's also Roy Jenkins and Enoch Powell. And the standard of kind of intellectual engagement, of understanding of the issues, what they expect of the audience. So what's changed?
辩论，我想，这次公投期间进行的，你也看了很多2016年的辩论。是的。辩论的标准如何比较？根本没有可比性。1975年的标准，说它高于2016年，简直是严重低估了它。我的意思是，水平，如果你，有一个，有一个，比如罗伊·詹金斯和托尼·本之间精彩的辩论，你可以在网上看到。我认为是这样，还有罗伊·詹金斯和以诺·鲍威尔。以及那种知识参与的水平，对问题的理解，他们对观众的期望。那么什么变了？
The media ecosystem changes. It's the media, do you think? Or the politicians or what? Both. I think they're both changed simultaneously. I think the people going into politics aren't as good and the media demands different things, which makes it impossible for them to communicate at the same length
媒体生态系统变了。你认为是媒体吗？还是政治家，或者是什么？两者都是。我认为他们同时改变了。我认为进入政界的人不如以前好了，媒体要求不同的东西，这使得他们不可能以同样的长度
or with the same depth or complexity. And frankly, we've changed probably as consumers. Our attention spans are shorter. You know, we don't want to listen to Roy Jenkins speak for 10 minutes on the principle of subsidiarity or Enoch Powell speaking for 10 minutes about what sovereignty really means. I mean, most people would be bored and would switch off.
或同样的深度或复杂性进行交流。坦率地说，我们作为消费者可能也变了。我们的注意力持续时间更短了。你知道，我们不想听罗伊·詹金斯谈论10分钟的辅助性原则，也不想听以诺·鲍威尔谈论10分钟的主权到底意味着什么。我的意思是，大多数人会感到无聊并关掉电视。
And that's probably one of the. things that's changed. What do the great British people think? They don't care. Simple as that. Polls show Europe doesn't matter to people. They are told again and again by all of these people, especially in the no campaign. Europe is a deadly threat to British sovereignty. So Labor's Cabinet Minister, Peter Shaw, he said, if we vote yes and we stay in Europe in the European community, it will mean the long and famous story of the British nation and people has ended, that we're now so weak and powerless that we must accept terms and conditions,
这可能是改变的事情之一。伟大的英国人民怎么想？他们不在乎。就这么简单。民意调查显示欧洲对人们来说并不重要。他们被所有这些人，特别是在“不”运动中，一次又一次地告知。欧洲是对英国主权的致命威胁。所以工党内阁大臣彼得·肖说，如果我们投赞成票并留在欧洲共同体，这意味着英国民族和人民漫长而著名的故事已经结束，我们现在如此虚弱和无力，以至于我们必须接受条款和条件，
penalties and limitations as though we'd suffer defeat in war. And people just, they don't want to listen. And the paradox of this, and I think this is the really interesting thing, the paradox of this is that all the evidence shows that the British people in the 70s were pretty Eurosceptic. So remember that before we entered, the polls and surveys showed that people were generally against it or indifferent. And after the referendum, polls showed the same thing.
惩罚和限制，就好像我们在战争中遭受了失败一样。人们只是，他们不想听。这个悖论，我认为这是真正有趣的地方，这个悖论是，所有证据都表明70年代的英国人民相当欧洲怀疑论。所以记住，在我们加入之前，民意调查和调查显示人们普遍反对或漠不关心。公投后，民意调查显示了同样的情况。
So in 1978, 48% said being in Europe was bad for Britain and in 25% good. In 1980, so after Margaret Thatcher's become Prime Minister, 60% said they would vote to leave if they were given the chance. So what's different in 1975? I think part of it is the campaign itself. So every newspaper pretty much is overwhelmingly pro-European. The Daily Mail does a big sort of Sanbrook-Crow. crystal ball style piece, saying this is what would happen if we left.
所以在1978年，48%的人说留在欧洲对英国不利，25%的人说好。在1980年，也就是玛格丽特·撒切尔成为首相后，60%的人说如果给他们机会，他们会投票离开。那么1975年有什么不同？我认为部分原因是竞选本身。所以几乎每一份报纸都压倒性地支持欧洲。《每日邮报》做了一篇大型的桑布鲁克-克劳式的，水晶球风格的文章，说如果我们离开会发生什么。
There would be no coffee, no wine, no beans or bananas. No oranges, yeah. Siege Britain, isn't it? Seedged Britain, exactly. The big thing, however, is the economic context. This is precisely the point when inflation is ripping through the British economy. Wages are rising at 30% a year. There are all those apocalyptic predictions.
没有咖啡，没有葡萄酒，没有豆子或香蕉。没有橙子，是的。被围困的英国，不是吗？被围困的英国，没错。然而，最重要的事情是经济背景。这正是通货膨胀在英国经济中肆虐的时候。工资每年上涨30%。有所有那些末日般的预测。
We're heading into, you know, we're turning into Weimar, Germany. We're heading for a dictatorship. and most people think, well, against this backdrop, getting out of you... I mean, I don't think they'd have got in in 1975. I think they'd have been more hesitant. They'd have stuck to the status quo. But at this point, Europe is the status quo, and they don't want to rock the boat. So always keep a hold of nurse, for fear of something worse.
我们正在走向，你知道，我们正在变成魏玛德国。我们正在走向独裁。大多数人认为，好吧，在这种背景下，退出欧洲……我的意思是，我不认为他们在1975年能成功。我认为他们会更犹豫。他们会坚持现状。但此时，欧洲就是现状，他们不想破坏现状。所以总是要守住护士，以免发生更糟的事情。
So we get towards the election day. Actually, you're asking about the standard of the debate. I mean, the very last action of the campaign, I mean, this tells you so much about the difference, is a two-hour debate at the Oxford Union, which was shown live on the BBC, and it had Ted Heath and Jeremy Thorpe in dinner jackets against Barbara Castle and Peter Shaw. And you can watch a lot of clips of that on YouTube again,
所以我们接近选举日。实际上，你在问辩论的标准。我的意思是，竞选的最后一个动作，我的意思是，这说明了差异，是牛津联盟的一场两小时辩论，在BBC直播，泰德·希思和杰里米·索普穿着晚礼服对抗芭芭拉·卡索和彼得·肖。你可以在YouTube上再次观看很多片段，
and the contrast with 2016 is just so embarrassing and depressing, because it's so much better. Anyway, Thursday, the 5th of June, the people vote, and everyone knows the yes campaign are going to win. Wilson votes yes, his wife, Mary, vote no, His controller, Marcia, she also votes no, interestingly. The turnout is about 65%. The results come through the next day and 67% have voted to stay in.
与2016年的对比真是太尴尬和令人沮丧了，因为它好太多了。总之，6月5日星期四，人们投票，每个人都知道赞成阵营会赢。威尔逊投了赞成票，他的妻子玛丽投了反对票，他的主管玛西娅，有趣的是，她也投了反对票。投票率约为65%。结果第二天出来，67%的人投票支持留下。
They voted yes. So two-thirds majority. Interestingly, the most pro-European places in Britain are the richest and the most conservative. So Buckinghamshire, Surrey and West Sussex. And guess what the least European parts of the country are? Scotland. Scotland. They don't like Europe in Scotland and in Northern Ireland. So interesting in such a contrast with 2016.
他们投了赞成票。所以是三分之二的多数。有趣的是，英国最亲欧的地方是最富有和最保守的地方。所以白金汉郡、萨里郡和西萨塞克斯郡。猜猜这个国家最不亲欧的部分是哪里？苏格兰。苏格兰。他们在苏格兰和北爱尔兰不喜欢欧洲。所以这与2016年形成了鲜明的对比。
Also a contrast with 2016, the press are delighted that we've stayed in. So the Daily Mail, the most crushing victory in British political history, the effect of this thunderous yes will echo down the years. Very ironic. David's changed their tune. The great hero of the Yes campaign is Ted Heath.
也与2016年形成对比的是，媒体很高兴我们留下来了。所以《每日邮报》，英国政治史上最压倒性的胜利，这个雷鸣般的赞成的效果将在未来几年回响。非常讽刺。戴维改变了他们的调子。赞成阵营的伟大英雄是泰德·希思。
The Times called in the Achilles of the Achilles of the... the European cause. Margaret Thatcher paid a handsome tribute to him in the common. She said he deserves the campaign honours. How did Ted Heath react? Gracelessly. Oh, growth in the times. Head in hand, stony-faced.
《泰晤士报》称他是欧洲事业的阿喀琉斯。玛格丽特·撒切尔在下议院向他致以崇高的敬意。她说他应该获得竞选荣誉。泰德·希思有什么反应？毫无风度。哦，在《泰晤士报》上成长。双手抱头，面无表情。
He made no acknowledgments. Oh, he's brilliant. Tony Ben took it really graciously, I have to say. This is, again, a big difference with 2016. It tells you again how politics has changed. There were no calls for a second referendum. him. There were no allegations of, you know, skullduggery or anything like this. Tony Ben said, I've just been in receipt of a very big message from the British people and I read it loud and
他没有任何表示。哦，他太棒了。我必须说，托尼·本接受得非常大度。这再次与2016年有很大不同。它再次告诉你政治是如何改变的。没有人呼吁进行第二次公投。没有关于，你知道，欺诈之类的指控。托尼·本说，我刚刚收到了英国人民的一个非常大的信息，我读得大声且
clear. I mean, whatever he say about Tony Ben, he's a massive Democrat. The principle of democracy is fundamental to him. Completely it is. But it's a disaster for him because he's been humiliated. And a couple of days later, Harold Wilson is able to emasculate him completely, take him away from the Department of Industry and move him to the backwater of energy. and Ben absolutely loses it with Wilson. He describes it in his diaries. What you're doing is capitulating to the CBI, that's the business group,
清晰。我的意思是，无论人们怎么说托尼·本，他都是一个伟大的民主主义者。民主原则对他来说是根本。完全是。但这对他来说是一场灾难，因为他受到了羞辱。几天后，哈罗德·威尔逊能够完全阉割他，把他从工业部调到能源部的冷板凳上，本对威尔逊彻底发火了。他在日记里描述了这件事。你所做的是向CBI投降，那是商业团体，
to the Tory press and to the Tories. Do you think this is going to save you? You've made a great mistake. They'll be pleased for 24 hours, then they'll turn on you. The thing with Ben is, whenever you slap him down, he will never walk away.
向托利党媒体和托利党投降。你认为这能救你吗？你犯了一个大错。他们会高兴24小时，然后他们就会反过来对付你。关于本的事情是，无论你什么时候打压他，他永远不会走开。
He'll always stay in the cabinet at all costs. They'll take basically whatever he's given, which he does. So, at least one big issue has been resolved. or so it seems because of course Europe was not quite resolved but the bigger issue is that Britain is still sliding towards economic disaster there's a brilliant cartoon a couple of days after the result in the sun
他会不惜一切代价留在内阁。他们基本上会接受给他的任何东西，他也确实这么做了。所以，至少一个大问题已经解决了。或者看起来是这样，因为当然欧洲问题并没有完全解决，但更大的问题是英国仍在滑向经济灾难。在《太阳报》上，结果出来几天后有一幅精彩的漫画，
and it shows Harold Wilson and his ministers as animal tamers at a circus and they're waving their whips at a little mouse that is labelled referendum sideshow and behind them is rearing this tiger teeth bared fangs bed labelled economic crisis and the circus manager very nervously is saying to them, right lads, now you've finished playing with the mouse. Now you can see why.
它展示了哈罗德·威尔逊和他的部长们作为马戏团的驯兽师，他们挥舞着鞭子对着一只贴着“公投附带节目”标签的小老鼠，在他们身后是这只龇牙咧嘴、贴着“经济危机”标签的老虎，马戏团经理非常紧张地对他们说，好了小伙子们，现在你们玩够了老鼠。现在你们可以看到为什么了。
Inflation is almost 30% and just a few days after the referendum, the pound begins to slide and it goes down, down, down, day after day. The pressure mounting on Harold Wilson all the time. And six weeks after the referendum, he tells his press chief, Joe Haynes, that he has come to a dramatic decision. a bombshell that will transform British politics. But what that bombshell is, we will find out next time.
通货膨胀率接近30%，就在公投几天后，英镑开始下滑，一天又一天地跌跌不休。哈罗德·威尔逊身上的压力一直都在增加。公投六周后，他告诉他的新闻主管乔·海恩斯，他做出了一个戏剧性的决定。一个将改变英国政治的重磅炸弹。但那个重磅炸弹是什么，我们下次再揭晓。
And if you are a member of the Restis History Club, then of course you can hear that right now. Find out what that bombshell decision is. And if you would like to join them, then the rest is history.com awaits you. But in the meanwhile, thank you, Dominic. Thrilling stuff. We will see you next time.
如果你是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，那么当然你现在就可以听到。找出那个重磅炸弹决定是什么。如果你想加入他们，那么therestisistory.com在等着你。但与此同时，谢谢你，多米尼克。激动人心的内容。我们下次见。
Bye. Bye. Hi everybody. It's Dominic here. So we are in week three, as our Restis History Club members will surely know, of our mighty series about photography and history with special guest Chris Floyd, one of Britain's leading photographers. And the last two exclusive episodes, we looked at revolutions and we looked at music. But in this week's episode, we're on something a little bit more enticing. We are looking at the story of fashion. But as I say, this is exclusively for Restus History. members, however, we have a little snippet of it for you right here. These Glen Lutchford pictures are for Prada, is that right? And what immediately strikes me about them, and to describe them for people who are only
再见。再见。大家好。我是多米尼克。所以我们现在是第三周了，正如我们的“历史的其余部分”俱乐部成员肯定知道的那样，我们关于摄影和历史的强大系列节目，特别嘉宾是英国领先的摄影师之一克里斯·弗洛伊德。在过去两期的独家剧集中，我们看了革命，我们看了音乐。但在本周的剧集中，我们关注一些更诱人的东西。我们正在看时尚的故事。但正如我所说，这是“历史的其余部分”成员专享的，不过我们在这里为你准备了一小段片段。这些格伦·拉奇福德的照片是为普拉达拍的，对吧？让我立刻印象深刻的是，对于那些只
listening, they are very cinematic, they feel deliberately old-fashioned. So they're in a boat, a rowing boat, it looks like. It's on the River Tiber. They had the river shut down for the shoot. Wow. It was for the autumn, winter, 97 Prada campaign. He said they had the money to pay the city of Rome, close off the river. You've got, in the background, people setting fire to what I think are bales of hay to create smoke and stuff.
听的人来说，它们非常有电影感，它们感觉故意老派。所以他们在船上，一艘划艇，看起来是这样。是在台伯河上。他们为了拍摄把河封锁了。哇。那是97年秋冬普拉达的广告活动。他说他们有钱付给罗马市，封锁河流。你在背景中看到，人们点燃了我认为是干草捆的东西来制造烟雾之类的。
He said in his email to me, an extra note, as I know Dominic has a special place in his heart for the US in 1968. When I was growing up, we didn't have any art books, but my dad bring one Time Life book home, which I studied in great detail. Specifically, one picture by Time Life photographer Bill Eppbridge. his picture of Bobby Kennedy dying on the floor of the Ambassador Hotel Kitchen looking back it had a film noir quality which I found alluring
他在给我的电子邮件中说，一个额外的说明，因为我知道多米尼克心中对1968年的美国有特殊的位置。当我长大的时候，我们没有任何艺术书籍，但我爸爸带回家一本《时代生活》书，我非常详细地研究了它。特别是《时代生活》摄影师比尔·埃普里奇的一张照片。他拍摄的鲍比·肯尼迪在大使酒店厨房地板上垂死的照片，回想起来，它有一种我发现很吸引人的黑色电影质感。
the man in the picture unknown to nine-year-old me the contradiction between Bobby's movie star looks in his black suit yet stricken and obviously in great danger I'm not sure why it stayed with me but when I became a photographer I began to unconsciously replicate it my Prada pictures were definitely inspired by it
照片中的男人，九岁的我不知道，鲍比那身黑色西装下的电影明星外表与他受重伤且显然处于巨大危险中的矛盾。我不确定为什么它一直留在我的脑海里，但当我成为一名摄影师时，我开始下意识地复制它。我的普拉达照片绝对是受它启发的。
years later Bill Epridge became my neighbour in Connecticut and would come to lunch on occasion and we talked in great detail about this day. Bill told him that he and Bobby became good friends on the campaign trail and he shared many anecdotes from that period. And he said one thing was that
多年后，比尔·埃普里奇成了我在康涅狄格州的邻居，偶尔会来吃午饭，我们详细谈论了那天。比尔告诉他，他和鲍比在竞选活动中成了好朋友，他分享了那个时期的许多轶事。他说有一件事是，
during Bobby Kennedy, when he was making his speech... Yeah, that's the hotel in L.A. Yeah, one of his aides whispered to Bill Eppbridge, he's going to go out the front door, go and wait for him by the front door. And then at some point later, someone went to Kennedy and said, actually, there's some donors in the kitchen
在鲍比·肯尼迪演讲时……是的，那是洛杉矶的酒店。是的，他的一名助手对比尔·埃普里奇耳语说，他要从前门出去，去前门等他。然后后来在某个时候，有人去找肯尼迪说，实际上厨房里有一些捐赠者
that want to meet you. We've got to go out of the back. do I meet the donors on the way out, and that's when he was shot in the kitchen. Bill then goes storming back through the hotel, and it's Bill Epprich that took that picture. And he said that although they had become great friends on the campaign, Ethel Kennedy never forgave him for taking pictures instead of helping,
想见你。我们得从后门出去。我在出去的路上见捐赠者，就在那时他在厨房被枪杀了。比尔随后冲回酒店，是比尔·埃普里奇拍下了那张照片。他说，虽然他们在竞选活动中成了好朋友，但埃塞尔·肯尼迪从未原谅他拍照而不是帮忙，
and she never spoke to him again. Well, that's the issue that photographers always confront, isn't it? You're just a bystander chronicling, or are you going to intervene? Yeah. And by and large photographers don't intervene, do they? No. It's not there, even. So out of that comes this beautiful fashion,
她再也没有和他说过话。嗯，这就是摄影师总是面临的问题，不是吗？你只是一个记录的旁观者，还是你要干预？是的。总的来说，摄影师不会干预，对吧？不。甚至不在那里。所以从中产生了这种美丽的时尚，
fashion imagery, which I would never have put the two and two together if he hadn't told me that. Right. Well, it's a reminder of how interlinked all these things are, I suppose. So thank you for listening to that little extract. Now, if you enjoyed what you heard and you want to hear more, you can of course subscribe by going to the rest is history.com and you sign up and you get a host of unbelievable benefits as well. So on that bombshell, thank you very much for listening and goodbye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
时尚意象，如果他没告诉我，我永远不会把这两件事联系在一起。好吧。嗯，这提醒我们所有这些事情是多么紧密地联系在一起，我想。所以谢谢你听那段小摘录。现在，如果你喜欢你听到的内容并且想听更多，你当然可以通过访问therestisistory.com订阅，你注册后还可以获得一系列令人难以置信的好处。所以在那颗重磅炸弹上，非常感谢你的收听，再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。